.
Thank you.
I want to be here.
This could be your day to just rush out the next room and say, okay, we're done.
Don't we need a quorum?
Do you need a quorum for committee work?
The hearing?
It's not like we're going to executive session.
Yeah.
You're probably right.
Your microphone's on.
How do you turn it off?
Thank you.
We're going to get started.
And the first bill we have is House Bill 1189, permitting voluntary donations to municipalities or the state to fund certain projects or to reduce taxation.
Just some information before we get started.
If you want to speak after you recognize, thank you.
All right.
If you want to speak after you recognize, you press the button, and the red light will come on.
I have control of everybody's mic, so I'll.
With one button, I can mute everybody.
And we'll let only one person speak at a time.
I imagine there's a few more members will be coming in, but we're going to start the public hearing because it was scheduled to start at 9 o'clock.
Since the prime sponsor cannot be here, then Representative Tudor, Rockingham 1.
I'm going to be reading a prepared statement from Representative Sody from Rockingham 7.
He is out sick today.
I'd like to introduce HB 1189.
This bill looks to enable and encourage voluntary funding from individuals of means or corporations for state and municipal projects and expenses, thereby reducing taxation.
These donations, I believe, are tax deductible from federal income taxes.
This, along with suitable recognition, as seen fit by the governing body, serves as motivating factors for potential donors.
Recognition would serve in much the same way as on PBS when they announced Program Z was brought to you by Y Corporation.
Anyone who donated a large sum of money for the project, school bus, fire truck, can have a plaque or sign in recognition of the donation placed on the building or vehicle.
The bill also establishes the availability of making donations to the state and municipality websites, thereby serving the same role as a GoFundMe page.
I believe the bill has great potential, especially with input from the committee.
Thank you for your consideration.
Representative Soty, Winnem.
Representative Romney.
Yeah.
Did you read that this would be federally tax deductible?
Did I hear that right?
Is that what he's saying?
That's what he's saying, yes.
Okay.
We've got to double-check that.
These donations, I believe, are tax deductible from the federal income taxes.
And we will get a reply to that.
Anybody have questions thank you representative I have a pink card from Elliot axelman who's from hooks that representing himself in support of the bill.
Can you hear me now?
Hi, my name is Elliot Axelman.
I'm representing myself.
I'm supporting House Bill 1189.
I think it's a very simple bill in a sense, but it could also be transformational.
It can start really eliminating the need for mandatory taxation as we know it.
But it's a very simple bill.
It allows for something.
I think it's already allowed.
The state government and town and city governments already do this, but it clarifies that it's allowed, and I think this bill would encourage the state government and town and city governments to do this.
It essentially has a program.
It clarifies a program where businesses, individuals can give money to the government, which they already can do, and it clarifies that the government should give them something in return.
So currently, we have many ways that the state government raises revenue voluntarily.
Like all people have to get revenue voluntarily.
They can't take it by force.
This kind of puts the government on a level playing field, and it says if they want to make money, they should do it voluntarily by giving something in exchange for it.
So currently we have sponsor a highway, adopt a highway.
We have the state and city governments and town governments.
They give something in exchange to people and businesses.
They give essentially advertising to businesses by sponsor a highway, by local police and fire trucks that we have throughout the state where they have a little plaque on the side of the police car.
Manchester police have seen this.
I think other towns, the buses in Nashua and Manchester do this a little bit.
The bus stops do this.
They have little advertisements.
So essentially, if I live in Hoekset and I want to get advertisement for my website or my business or anything, I can give $1,000 a month to the Hoekset Fire Department or any department or Hooks at Town Government, and I can negotiate with them to put a plaque saying sponsored by Alu's website or any business sponsored by on the fire truck.
So I feel I'm getting something, so I'm happy.
The town gets something, they get money for their funding for their new fire trucks, they're happy, and the taxpayers get offset taxation by that same amount., I figure if every town can raise the amount they need for their budget and on the state level if the state can raise six billion a year, which I know they can, they can, we can eventually offset taxation.
So the state government's budget is around six billion a year right now.
We have the state government owns a few buildings, a few thousand vehicles and thousands of miles of roadways.
If they can essentially rent out or sell advertisements on what are essentially billboards, I think the state government can raise $6 billion a year ultimately in a few years with this program by having advertising because they have essentially thousands of billboards, meaning they can make $6 billion a year voluntarily by selling ads essentially to private business.
So eventually we can make all taxation essentially into more of an advertising system and eventually offset taxation as we know it.
So I'd love to take questions.
Representative Barone.
Thank you for your testimony.
Can you hear me?
Okay.
So I'm going to ask the same question about, I guess, the statement that was read from the prime sponsor said that this would be tax-deductible donations.
Are we certain of that?
I have no idea.
I saw that in Julius Sodi's email, the prime sponsor.
He said he believes it would be.
I have no idea.
We'd have to look at the experts with taxation.
We'll take care of it.
I think what he was saying was if it's considered, because right now it's not necessarily taxation, it's not really a donation to the state, if it's considered a state tax, that state taxes with the SALT, depending on the rates, might be tax deductible federally, but I'm definitely not the expert on that.
Okay, thank you.
Representative.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and welcome to Ways and Means, Representative.
Right now, there's a baseball stadium in Manchester with a corporate name on it.
So isn't this already allowed?
I guess the city of Manchester owns the ballpark.
Yeah, well, I know it's definitely being done a little bit.
I saw a few months ago, Manchester police, their mounted units, so their horses and the trailer, it's set sponsored by, I think, St.
Mary's Bank, a few other credit unions, and a few other businesses.
So it's already being done on the city level maybe on a state level too so it's definitely being done a little bit that's why when I spoke to the representatives crafting this bill and stuff we knew it was already happening but this bill kind of clarifies that it can happen and I think encourages the town and city governments and the state government to do this the bill also mentions they should put it on the.
They should mention on the state government and city websites that you can donate here and we can compensate you to give you something in exchange for it.
And some might want to consider an amendment to make it mandatory for towns and cities and the state government to accept this program for advertising.
Right now, the bill says they may do it if the executive wants to do it to do it um so they're that's a good interesting question if it should be mandatory or not but definitely to answer the question the cities and towns some are already doing this for sure okay thank you uh representative mulloy thank you mr chair for taking my question uh and recognizing me, and thank you for taking my question.
Before I ask my question, I want to let you know that I spent 25 years working for public television.
And my first question is, would you believe that I think the characterization of this, comparing this to a public television kind of thing is oversimplistic.
Can I have a follow-up?
I'm not sure.
I think that was Representative Soty who mentioned it.
I hadn't thought of it as compared to public television, and I don't have the expertise you have in public television.
But I think I was thinking of it as advertising and using billboards.
I'm not an expert in billboards either, but I figure the state government has how many buildings the state government owns, maybe a few dozen or a few hundred and thousands of vehicles and roadways and everything else the state owns and the websites.
That can all be rented out to advertisers to make, I would think, a substantial impact off the taxation.
So that's what I was thinking about.
But I guess TV could be a small portion of the advertising as well, as far as public access TV.
No, I'm not suggesting that it should be television involved in this.
I'm just saying, by my follow-up, may I follow-up?
In my experience, this type of fundraising for public television amounted maybe 10% of its entire budget and I think that that I want to go on record here as asking the question do you believe really believe with that knowledge now that there would be that kind of money coming into state and local coffers that you said to the six billion I think you said would really is realistic.
Yeah that's a good question.
I think ultimately this is kind of a no loss no downside proposition because there's no downside the government can raise revenue if they can offset taxation on a state and local level by even 5%.
That's phenomenal for the taxpayers who are on fixed incomes who are struggling with taxes.
That being said, I do think the state government owning what are essentially thousands of billboards can make $6 billion a year.
I do think this program can eventually raise all the revenue without taxation.
Will that happen in an instant, in two days after the bill passes?
Probably not.
But I think ultimately, put it this way, if I had 10,000, 50,000 billboards, I think I could raise $6 billion a year.
I don't know the exact rates, but there will be price discovery.
And as soon as this program were launched, we would have Amazon and Google and Facebook competing for that ad space on essentially digital billboards or other type alternative billboards, like the buildings and vehicles.
Every state vehicle, the state probably owns thousands of vehicles, all the state police and other programs and DPW and all that.
If you rent out, lease out every part of every vehicle with stickers and logos for Amazon, Bezos is probably willing to pay a few thousand bucks a month or a few million a month for that, right?
So I do think $6 billion could easily be reached if you have thousands of what are essentially billboards.
So does that make sense?
Thank you for your response.
Further questions?
Representative Janigian.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
I don't see anything in here that would prevent this, Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
I don't see anything in here that would prevent this, but I just wanted to ask you.
So if somebody makes a donation, is the government required to use that donation for the purpose that the person giving it specifies for?
Because if that's true, then I'd be concerned that people could make donations for all sorts of things that may not relate to what the state or government would be using money for.
Yeah, that's an excellent question.
At least to me, as written, that seems unclear in the bill.
I think Representative Soty shares that sentiment.
He said it when I spoke to him the other night.
He said it was unclear.
And the bill says that a person can donate to the government for the reasons of offsetting taxation or a new project or something like that.
I think ultimately it would be up to the executive of that government or of that department.
And what I'm kind of imagining in this bill, again, it's kind of unprecedented.
What I'm imagining is I have a website.
I think it's a great website publication about freedom, and I want advertisement for it.
I would go to, let's say, my town government and negotiate with them and say, for $87 a month, I would like a plaque of eight inches by six inches on the fire truck for one month.
And we would negotiate and sign a contract, and then we'd go from there.
And if they didn't want to do that, we wouldn't do it.
So I'm imagining there would be kind of specific contracts for each instance of the advertising.
Thank you.
Representative Ames.
Sorry.
Hi.
I came in a little late, so I didn't catch your name.
It's Elliot Axelman.
Thank you.
So, thinking to your reference to maybe Amazon or some huge corporation would rise to this opportunity and donate significant sums of money, perhaps in return for some expected good publicity.
Isn't there a real danger in moving down that road that you create a dependent relationship on a major corporation such that the municipality or the state finds it difficult to move forward with policy actions that Amazon or, I hate to use a particular company, that the major company doesn't really want the government to get into.
And so then you have a single private entity affecting public policy in a distorted way.
Yeah, thank you.
That's an excellent question.
And I was just speaking to a few representatives before this hearing about that concern.
And that is one of the concerns that I've heard about this type of program, about private entities essentially having influence on government.
A few things I would say in regards to that concern is currently we have obviously on-the-record lobbying, off-the-record lobbying, other donations, other cronyist contracts that federal and state government has with nepotism, with people who are close to government officials.
And that's kind of behind the scenes.
This is very transparent where everyone knows, because it's very public, and it's an advertisement of it, that a business is giving money to the government.
So it's very transparent.
So if we're going to have a private entity giving money to a government I would much prefer it be the public so everyone knows about it but also it being used not to go to a politicians pockets but to be used to literally fund that new fire truck we need right so so on a smaller level or if Amazon does buy ads they're literally giving money to the government to be used for a program So it's not going to you know some congressman's pocket or to some foreign country Corrupt politician is going to literally helping a town with schools and fire trucks so Yeah, that's what I would say.
It's literally helping the town raise more money And it's better in public view than more kind of under the table Corrupt donations as far as lobbying or unofficial lobbying or other corrupt stuff.
Representative Almey.
Thank you.
I come from Lebanon.
Lebanon is right on 89, has three exits, four maybe if you count them right.
we have the center we are the center.
We are the center of a micropolis of 100,000 people.
We have an excellent opportunity, if you did this, to buy up all the advertising that the advertisers are going to want to use and leave Hanover, which is off this system, and all of the smaller bedroom towns around us with a no revenue source.
Why would an advertiser, except a local person, want to fund the fire trucks in Canaan or in Hanover?
I'm not sure I understood the first part, but as far as the latest thing you asked, why would a bigger company want to do it, mostly local?
I don't know.
Again, I can't say for sure because this hasn't happened before.
I would think a lot of local businesses would certainly want to help out their town and get publicity on a local level in the micro economy.
I also think I could totally see larger companies wanting to get great publicity as far as helping to fund that new fire truck and school and police department.
But also, it is advertising.
So they're doing calculations, right?
So Amazon and Google are doing calculations every day with their advertising budget.
So maybe Amazon spends $1 billion a year on advertising, and some of it is big.
It's on national things.
Some of it is going to be Super Bowl and YouTube.
Some of it is going to be on local fire departments, and then they can come out with a press release saying, we're helping 400 fire departments around the United States buy new fire trucks.
So that's great publicity, too.
But you're right.
It's probably going to be more local, but I don't know, I can't say for sure.
But I do see this being very much local businesses wanting to get great publicity for helping their town and get actual benefit from advertising from people seeing their logo, their business and around the town.
Thank you.
Could I just have a short follow-up?
Follow-up.
Do you believe that if you went out into the smaller towns of our state, that you would not find even a gas station?
I'm not sure.
Thank you.
Representative Decette.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
I kind of, in thinking about this briefly, if I read the legislation, proposed legislation correctly, it's up to the towns, the localities accept the dollars now if we had organization a offer to sponsor a police cruiser an organization B offered to sponsor a police cruiser the town decides to go with the organization A as opposed to organization B.
Whose exposure is that?
And I need not elaborate on where I'm going with this, but there are some organizations I don't want on my fire truck in my town.
So what's your thoughts on that, Elliot?
Yeah, that's a great question.
And I think we thought about that over the last few weeks a little bit.
There's a few things we could say.
And, again, that's not clear.
Right now in the legislation, it's very short, simple legislation.
It's not clear.
So on one hand, the town manager or on the state level, the governor, may choose to accept the highest bidder, and we could amend the bill, or that could just be the policy where they accept the highest bidder.
Or if it's a business you don't want to associate with because either it's for adults only or something like that, or just an organization that that government doesn't want to associate with, they could choose not to.
But on the other hand, we have to make sure there isn't too much corruption as far as going with a friend's business as far as corrupt contracts.
So that's a concern.
And again, I don't have the answer to how to remedy that.
On one hand, you could say you should accept the highest bidder.
That way, the government can get the most money for that advertisement, that limited space of advertisement on that limited billboard.
On the other hand, maybe there should be some businesses that they don't accept.
I don't know.
But that's something that could be either amended or up to each executive.
So again, a state should trust its governor to make those judgment calls.
A town should trust their town manager or a city should trust their mayor to do the right thing as far as taking the highest bidder and or taking the most appropriate business, if that makes a little sense.
Follow up, Mr.
Chair.
I'm just wondering where, if the thought process in drafting this, if, how do I say this without being offensive, if, in fact, whomever the organization, party, group, or whatever is chosen, they're the high bidder.
If there is a loss, whose exposure is that?
Is that the locality's exposure?
If there's a legal action after that, or do you think it'd be the state and the legislature's exposure in bringing this into law?
I'm not sure, and I probably couldn't answer it anyway, but what sort of legal action are you concerned with?
If, in fact, let's say an organization that has proven to be detrimental to the community, just big picture here and they come in with with the biggest bid and they put on a fire truck whatever their logo is and they caused harm to the community as opposed to another organization that does good for the community I'm just trying to think ahead of legal action we may be exposed to either as a state or as a locality in my town of Salem.
Without invoking names of organizations, I can see organizations coming forward and wanting to buy ad space on my fire truck that I don't necessarily want ad space from that organization.
And if I don't agree with my town manager, my town manager wants to have that ad space on his fire truck, there may be some exposure for somebody there.
Yeah, I probably couldn't answer that question satisfactorily.
As far as a logo being on the side of a fire truck hurting someone, I've never heard of seeing a logo physically hurting a person.
But will there be lawsuits?
Yes.
Because if some, you know, I think Amazon, some people think, is not the best organization for the environment in the world.
And if they have a logo on my police car in my town, someone in the town is going to sue and say that, you know, that is contributing to harming the environment or something like that.
And there's going to be lawsuits.
So I'm sure there have been plenty of lawsuits.
I'm sure there will be lawsuits in the future.
That I have no doubt about.
And I probably couldn't answer that perfectly as far as who would handle that.
If it's on a town level, it would probably be the town.
If this is on a state level ad, it would probably be the state as far as their lawyers.
But yeah, I probably couldn't answer that perfectly.
It's an interesting question.
Representative Urily followed by Representative Gamalo and Abramny.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Following up a little bit on what Representative Doucette started down that path, let's say I'm a manufacturer of fire trucks, Rescue 1, because they're in New England, not on the Cape.
If I were Rescue 1 and I wanted Town A to buy my fire trucks, I'd be willing to give them a discount if they put Rescue 1 all over the side.
That would be considered, if done outside of this law, quid pro quo.
But with this law, are you not creating a legalized quid pro quo?
Yeah, that's certainly possible.
And again, we'd have to speak to the exact lawyers as far as what that would create.
I think I understand you.
And now I think that I don't necessarily see massive downside.
I understand quid pro quo.
I don't see massive downside in the taxpayer saving a few million dollars.
In my town, I would love to save a few million dollars.
We just bought a fire truck.
It cost a few million dollars.
I think $1 million for an engine.
And if we could have gotten a discount on that, I would have been very happy.
So I understand that.
And I think some fire trucks, you know, in the ambulance business and all fire trucks, the logo is there, right?
So, for instance, almost every single ambulance in the United States, every ambulance I've been on is a Ford.
I've been on a few Chevys back in New York.
So that logo is there, right?
So they're getting free advertisement.
Ford is getting essentially free advertisement from every ambulance.
And it says Ford right there in front.
The logo is few inches big everyone sees an ambulance they see Ford is it quid pro quo does Ford give a discount to ambulance companies I don't know but I understand you know there's some concern with nepotism quid pro quo on the other hand if there are discounts discounts are good if taxpayers are saving money so I see both sides of that ultimately I would not probably not mind erring on the side of saving taxpayers' money, right?
Follow-up.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
The comment I would have on that, there's a world of difference between the badge of the vehicle owner, Ford for the Ford Explorer for the police cruisers or the F-350s for the trucks, for the ambulance trucks, or Seagrave or Rescue One or whichever one happens to be manufacturing the fire truck at the time.
France used to make them.
That's far different from the badge logo than having it donated by or on the side of it, which says one thing.
Do you see a difference in those things or not?
Yeah, I would agree that having a Ford, a vehicle being made by a Ford, is a little different than the vehicle being made and outfitted and then given to the town as far as a donation or a contract with them, for sure.
I think, at least, I don't know, fire trucks in the ambulance business, this already happens.
For instance, it's Ford, and then there's a company called Medix, M-E-D-I-X, that outfits the ambulances.
And that logo is on the inside, maybe the outside too, but on the inside of the ambulance, they're pretty big.
Their logo, they're the ones who outfitted the ambulance to make it an ambulance So it's already happening a little bit again I totally understand the concern of nepotism corporatism, you know advertising selling out to private businesses on the side of your fire engines It's supposed to be public admissible and it looks like it's private or Corrupt contracts or anything like that, but as far as quid pro quo But saving taxpayers money I think is a little just a little higher on my list as far as priorities.
If we could save taxpayers, you know, that grandma whose taxes are going up and she has to choose to pay her property tax bill or buy food for herself for the month, if we could save her a few hundred dollars that month and people have to see a logo on the side of a fire truck, I think I'd rather harm someone by making them see a logo on a fire truck than harm my grandmother by making her starve, if that makes sense.
Representative Grumato, followed by Representative Bromley.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I read this a couple weeks ago, and I've perused it three or four times, and I see nothing about advertising.
I see that there can be voluntary donations made and acknowledgement on a website.
I see nothing about advertising so I'm wondering where that comes from.
Yeah that's a great question.
Thank you.
So I had some discussions with Representative Soty in crafting the bill.
I thought of it as more of an advertisement bill and he was thinking of it more as a donation bill.
But then when I read it, if you read the bill, it says acknowledgement for the donation as determined by the executive on the state level or town or city level being made essentially in concert between the donor, meaning the payer for the advertisement, and the executive, So town manager or governor so so by acknowledging for instance if I have a billboard and you were to donate money to me or give me money and I would acknowledge that by putting your business on my billboard that's essentially advertising so I know the bill it is you know interesting and I didn't write the bill it's interesting to say the word advertisement if I wrote it or I were OLS, I probably would have put the word advertisement in there for sure.
But by giving money and acknowledging that someone is a donor, by giving them either a plaque in a hospital or on a park bench or a bigger billboard type thing, I think that satisfies that it is an advertisement type of program.
Representative Brownlee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Yeah, thanks again for taking my question.
Yeah, I was going to bring this up.
It's actually line 16, everybody.
It says the governing body may approve suitable recognition of donations as they see fit.
So I guess you're interpreting that as if the town wants to advertise, they can advertise.
Yeah, and what I'm hoping that does is I'm hoping that kind of makes like a contract where if I give you money, either I trust you or we have some kind of contract where I'm going to give you $1,000 a month.
I'm hoping you will put my website logo on the side of your fire trucks and police cars as I requested.
So that's not 100% clear, but I'm hoping that's kind of where it goes.
I'd like you, but I'm not going to give you $1,000 a month if I don't get anything in return.
So that's what I'm hoping.
So it's not unheard of of quasi-public entities like the Metropolitan Transit Authority in New York City.
They put placards up on their subway cars, etc.
But I'm not too thrilled with this idea.
How would you feel if that line, 16, is eliminated?
Most of this conversation has been around the advertising part.
And, you know, it's up to the committee how we all feel about that.
But the essence of the bill would still be there if people want to donate to the town or to the state.
But I could see problems, too, in terms of you can upset somebody if you're advertising one product versus another product on a town or a state property so I just need you to react to that if we were to edit that out and amend that out would it how much damage would it do to the bill in your mind?
Cutting out line 16 says what exactly?
Line 16 says, the governing body may approve suitable recognition of donations as they see fit.
And that's the only line that seems to kind of imply advertising.
Yeah.
Because there's nothing in here about advertising.
That's the only line.
Yeah.
Well, without that line, I don't know how many people will donate to the state government and towns, right?
So as much as people may love you, if they're not going to get recognition for it, meaning advertisement, I'm not going to be giving you a few million dollars of my hard-earned money if I'm not going to get anything in return, right?
So, you know, people, you know, it's very simple.
People do things in exchange for other things.
It's just transaction, right?
There are people who donate things to charities and sometimes get recognition, sometimes don't.
But as far as anonymous donors to charities or government, which, you know, people are a little more sympathetic to various charities than they are to government.
So without recognition as far as advertisement, that's what I think makes this bill special.
When I said the state government can raise $6 billion, I wasn't joking.
I wasn't exaggerating.
They can if they give people reason to donate six billion a year, right?
If you give someone a reason to give you money by giving them a product or a service, they'll give you money.
If you don't, if I don't offer anything and I ask for money, I'm probably going to get very little money if I just ask for money and give nothing in return.
So I think that's what makes this bill.
And you also mentioned that if a town accepts one bid and doesn't the other, someone could be offended.
And that's true.
Someone could be offended.
And that's why there will be price discovery by bidding and the price will be bid up, which is a good thing because the town will get more money by willing payers without taking money by forced by taxation.
If I bid $100, Amazon bids $150, I bid $200, the town just got $200 it's it's it's it's bidding so it's I forget the word for yes it's a bidding up the price essentially so that's I think it's a good thing if the town is getting more money so if there's competition that's a good thing even if someone might be offended if they lose if they lose that I think I think you made your point.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
We have a couple more.
Representative Janine.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Just a quick question.
I agree with Representative Abrami that line 16 does seem to be where most of the controversy in this is.
And if that was taken out, it may decrease donations a little bit, but the donator or the person Thank you.
most of the controversy in this is, and if that was taken out, it may decrease donations a little bit, but the donator or the person making a donation still has the website.
And there'll be a, people will begin to learn in town and states that if I want to see who's funding certain things, they still have the website to go through.
So I think the website ends up being a less, you know, there will be people offended by various organizations they don't agree with.
But on the website, I think that, would you believe, I think that would probably not be as big a deal.
Yes, I think that part, so line 16 is the controversial part of the bill, but it's also, it makes the bill a bill.
Without it, it would be essentially neutered.
It wouldn't do anything.
So the bill essentially allows the government to raise money, because right now, I'm sure you guys know this, in the Liffordie State, there are hundreds of thousands of people who don't like paying taxes.
They want to pay little to no taxes.
And this bill would make them all very happy because it would start the process of explaining and clarifying that the government and encouraging the government to raise money voluntarily, without force, without taxation, voluntarily raising money by offering something in return.
And there is something the government can offer in return is they already have all this real estate.
We have the LOB, we have the state house and tons of buildings and vehicles and the roads and like you said, websites are digital billboards essentially.
There's a lot of advertising on websites.
If they were recognized on the website, yes, that would be worth like three dollars to me a month.
I'm just thinking myself for my small business, my publication.
I would donate around three dollars maybe a month to the state if I were recognized in a small part of the website saying I donated.
If you were to put my logo of my big beautiful website, Liberty Block, on the side of the LOB, if it's a 10 foot by 5 foot poster, I would probably pay a few hundred or a few thousand dollars a month for that.
And the bids go up from there.
So, you know, a bigger company with more money, my advertising budget is not very big, it's a few dollars, but a bigger company that's going to spend billions a year, if you really give them a reason to give you money by giving them ad space, then they might give millions or billions a year.
So I think that's what makes it a bill.
I understand it's controversial, and that's the sticking point for everyone here, and I understand that.
But without line 16, the bill doesn't really do anything.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
And no further questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you very much.
Next, we have Russon Chester from Bedford, New Hampshire, in support of the bill, representing himself.
Russin.
No worries.
I'm sorry.
It's the first time ever.
Dad's name's Russell.
Mother's name's Sandra.
Born in the 60s here in Concord, New Hampshire.
Well, welcome aboard.
Thank you.
I am here in support of this bill.
I recently became a lot more aware of the monies that are going to my tax dollars that are going to all these different programs some of which I approve of some of which I don't both on a state level local level state level and federal level so the bottom line is is this bill just takes that money from out from under to put it out there where people say well, they obviously are being paid to put that on their thing.
I mean, liken this bill to the car dealerships.
When you go to a car dealership and you buy a car, they put their little logo right on the side.
Everybody knows where you bought that car.
Free advertisement for that car company.
And hopefully you got a good deal from the salesman so that people will you know there'll be conversations about that speak a little bit about I'm going to use Amazon no no offense but I know a lot about the Amazon situation with Hookset and for instance there are a lot of people that were really not comfortable with the amount of, with Amazon being able to go into the old skating rink facility in Hookset.
A lot of people were really uncomfortable with that.
They felt that there was some unhandedness about monies being passed to the people in power to get that approved.
And this bill would take that power away too.
So the way I feel about this bill is it's much more transparent.
It allows for transparency.
For instance, we have a House of Representatives person right now who almost $90,000 of his $200,000 campaign fund, $90,000 that came from big pharmaceutical and medical agencies, and he is the one that's supporting all of these vaccine mandates.
You have a lot of people that are very upset about that.
So if we pass this type of bill, we're saying we are, we, the state of New Hampshire, agrees to be a more transparent government for our people, and we understand that people may be upset about our choices.
For instance, Manchester does do a lot of the advertising now.
They actually have representation through a body.
So when someone says, I want to advertise on your buses, what happens is someone comes in and says, I want to advertise on your buses.
And they're like, okay, great.
Tell us a little bit about your company.
Let us do some vetting.
And we'll see if you, you know, we'll develop a proposal for you on how much we're willing to spend or give.
very similar to what happens in the National Racing Committee you know you still you're sponsored by people but you they still have the oversight as to who or what you can put on your vehicles or so I really think that this bill is a very positive bill it's's a way to start giving back some of the trust in the people of New Hampshire, because a lot of people in New Hampshire has lost a lot of trust in our local, state, and federal government.
They don't believe in us anymore as a body, and they are starting to begin to feel as though they're being taxed without representation.
And that is a terrible, terrible way to feel.
Thank you for your testimony.
Questions from the committee?
Representative Bromley.
Okay.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
so to me if we keep this line 16 and we're really looking at commercializing the state in our towns.
I mean, plus, Amazon, for example, you'd be upsetting all of Main Street, all of our Main Streets, all of our Main Street stores who are competing against Amazon.
I can see that being a real problem as well.
I'm going to ask you.
Yes, I do.
So would you accept if we got rid of line 16?
I agree with Elliot with regards to line 16.
I mean, the thing is, is the towns, the town municipalities, we the people trust our local government more than our state and federal government.
So the town municipality could create a committee or a group, let's say city council, town council, some kind of group that can further hone this state bill so that in your towns and municipalities, they would be able to hone it in such a way that says, and we do not allow, we will not allow corporations of over $2.4 billion to advertise in our local municipality.
If you want to do it on a state level, you know, that's one thing.
But if you want to do it in our town of Concord, no.
The town of Concord is going to be for our main street, our little guys, which is what makes New Hampshire and Concord fantastic.
And that would solve two problems.
One, it would stop the Amazons and some of the other huge corporations, including the large chain restaurants.
It would put life back into the little mom and pop restaurants because they have budgets that could afford to put the advertising in word of mouth.
The other thing is that by taking it to the point where it's just on the website, you're losing a lot of traffic.
The state of New Hampshire, the population in the state of New Hampshire, although some are very, very computer savvy and use the internet and the website a lot, many people on Main Street, you can go down on Main Street and you can talk to the people, and a lot of them don't often visit websites or are involved in that process whereas if there was a little in it doesn't have to necessarily be huge but there's something on there that says I'm gonna check that out I think it's important to start allowing people to have...
So by taking that out, we're eliminating some of our population by having it just on the website.
Any further questions?
No further representative?
Hold on one second.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Yeah, thank you.
Over here in the corner.
Thank you so much, Rossanne, for your testimony.
I have not your last name.
Could you?
Chester.
Thank you, Ms.
You know, I'm reading the language of this bill and I'm having some real difficulty understanding, I guess, security concerns that I think are relevant for our election system.
In particular, what would you say to the idea that a foreign entity or a large corporate shell company could be established in which they provide an extreme amount of dark money that is not regulated by our current election laws and makes the suggestion suggestion to the state or to a municipality we're going to give you so much money to replace all of your outdated voting system equipment and we're going to allow you to conduct an audit of the last election that you conducted to make sure that this new equipment is better suited to assist your future election systems.
Do you see that there could be any sort of place of mistrust for any of these corporations or foreign entities who set up these shell companies and provide these donations to our state or municipalities for a free and fair election in your state?
That's a great question.
Thank you for that.
I'm actually very involved with trying to get the voting machines out of the state of New Hampshire, period.
So I just want to be up front and totally transparent.
the company that we are currently using is a huge conglomerate company and is a shell corporation so that's a perfect example it would allow us to be transparent and we would have things in place where companies like this can be appropriately vetted so in my opinion this helps eliminate some of the chance for the nefarious money coming in because this would give all of us, the people of New Hampshire, our local and state government to take that what is happening now.
It goes out to the highest bidder.
We don't know that that bidder of that the PPE for 2020 was a nefarious company something like this you know I'm just I'm going off topic here a little bit but what I can say is something like this would make us more transparent because we would create appropriate resources to do vetting of companies to try and prevent some of this money that we don't want coming into our state or some of these quid pro quo type of things.
It would actually prevent it because that committee could actually start vetting the agencies appropriately instead of always taking the highest bidder.
If you have a short question.
I do have a short follow-up.
Thank you.
And hopefully response should be short.
Okay, thank you.
So I'm looking at page two of the language of the proposed bill.
In particular, this relates to the voluntary donations to the state.
You'll see on line 2 that it says the name of the donor of the donation under paragraph 1 shall be noted on the state's website.
In addition, oh, excuse me, yeah.
I'm not seeing anything here about, you know, any required disclosure about who the donor is other than a name so I'm not sure that we would be able to to vet them where were you getting that indication so on a state level or on a state level the way we would vet them is we would create a it would probably go through a finance group or finance committee along with another committee so it would be generating a committee that could do this this this bill in and of itself is very very broad and it allows for if we do this then eventually then eventually we can hone it in.
So this is kind of the big ball of marbles, and we want to get down here, but this will allow us to start working towards developing a good system.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
Any further questions?
Seeing none, then we'll go on to our next pink card.
Thank you.
And this is from Catherine Heck from the New Hampshire Municipal Association in support of the bill.
Good morning.
My name is Catherine Heck from the New Hampshire Municipal Association, and I'm here to testify in support of HB 1189 as it relates to municipalities.
So this bill provides a new financial tool for potential revenue capture for municipalities in the form of private donations outside of taxation so while donations are currently permitted and allowed and accepted by municipalities this bill actually creates a trust which allows a governing body to create an un-non lapsing trust fund and the voluntary donations can go into the trust that fit within the eligible uses outlined in the bill currently we have municipalities that accept donations to build a bandstand and the donors name might be on the bandstand or build a theater at their local school they also have street lights that were put up in a community by many donors and no names were placed just out of the kindness of their heart or our local municipal meeting places our ancient town halls are renovated with capital campaigns that don't necessarily have any donor names attached so while this is already occurring this does allow the governing body rather than the legislative body to create a trust and capture this form of revenue.
So due to the limits of taxation repairing a bridge is a costly endeavor maintaining parks roads and large capital projects could be funded through this financial tool it also allows for the grant making process which can highly competitive, to have an alternative option to seek private donations in a very transparent way.
So I appreciate your opportunity.
I did submit a letter.
And if you have any questions, I'd be happy to take them.
Thank you for your testimony.
Representative Bromley followed by Representative Almey.
All right.
Thank you for your testimony.
Appreciate it.
So I guess actually Representative Almey pointed out that if you go to the second page, lines three and four, it says, in addition, the governor may provide for suitable recognition of donations.
So that would be for the state properties.
I know you're just addressing the municipalities.
I asked you the same question I asked the other two.
If we took the line 16 out, what do you think will happen to the bill in terms of its effectiveness if we took 16 out?
We would not object to the removal of that line.
Okay, thank you.
Representative Almey.
Thank you.
I'm very confused about both parts of it, but the municipal part, which you deal with.
It sounds like the trust fund would be a common trust fund for any donations that came in.
It doesn't talk about whether each of those donations would come in with a stated purpose, which might not be a purpose that this municipal government actually wants to use it for, or it would come to a point where it was impossible to use it for that, and what would happen in that case, just anything that's in the trust fund and the trust fund's last sentence is any other authorized expenditure on including election audit costs which is totally unrelated to infrastructure or reducing taxation.
So I'd read that as saying that you could use this money for anything once it hit the trust fund.
Is that the way you look at this?
Or can you see depend on each town to make its own controls, which does vary in our state whether you're going to do that or not on or would it need a lot more work so currently under practice a town receiving any gift or donation has to account for that and use it for the purpose for which it was intended.
Exactly.
And accounting practices, best practices already require that.
So if they're following best practices and accounting standards, they would be using the gift for which it was intended.
And there's sub-accounting that would occur.
So every donation made should have a purpose attached to it so it can be tracked and followed through the accounting system.
So that would be an accounting best practice.
I can't speak to what authorized other expenditures would mean.
I think that would be the bill sponsor.
I can't speak to what those would be.
Follow-up.
Thank you.
Just a quick follow-up.
I don't really understand your distinction between I come from a city we've got a city council we have SB1 too in the school system but your distinction between the trust fund being under control of the municipal government or the legislative body, do you mean that in most towns that you have to take it for a vote of the citizenry?
That's correct.
And, well, we've done a lot of fundraising for our library system, for parks, for everything.
And we don't need this.
What is it that people really need that distinguishes this from what we already do?
All it does, you're absolutely correct that we do not necessarily need this.
The law already allows us to accept gifts and donations and to do a certain amount of fundraising for projects that the governing body or the legislative body sees fit.
This just allows another financial tool in which to do it by creating that trust.
Rep Son Urily.
I have two questions, and I would appreciate just succinct answers.
The first question is, is there any provision in this bill to reduce the tax rate as opposed to just spending money on stuff?
The bill allows for you to use the funds to reduce the tax rate or spend money on stuff.
It depends on donor intent.
Okay.
And the second question, is there any provision in this bill to prevent, say, I'll use a 1930s term, the Deutsche Bund organization from purchasing advertising on the side of a police cruiser?
I can't answer that legal question.
Are you aware of what the Deutsche Bund was?
No, sir.
Shall I explain?
A short explanation.
It was a pro-Nazi organization in the United States.
Thank you, sir.
Further questions?
Representative Ames.
I'm puzzling over what this bill adds to current law.
And you said that it allows another financial tool.
I guess you're referring to the Voluntary Donations Trust Fund?
That's correct.
Isn't it the case that a municipality can set up a voluntary donations trust fund already under current law?
For a specific purpose.
Excuse me?
I could qualify that answer, but my understanding is any trust fund has to be set up for a very specific purpose.
This broadens those purposes rather than having it be set up for a specific purpose.
If you find out any differently, would you let us know?
Yes, sir.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Representative Gamal.
Very brief.
Did the municipal association take into account that it might cost the town money to vet these companies and have somebody manage a trust fund and the inflowing donations and with some kind of system to track if it does work as anticipated?
Well, because it's under local control and a municipality can decide for itself whether or not they would like to engage in it, I would suppose that they would take that into account before they would accept the provision of this law and create this type of trust.
Any further questions?
Representative Malloy.
Thank you.
Thank you for taking my question.
To that last point, do you believe that there would be professional administrative staff to manage these donations to ensure they're applied to the purpose for which they were intended?
and that there would be another layer of management needed to execute this plan.
I believe the level of management needed to execute this plan, in my professional opinion, would be the same as it is under the current law, which allows municipalities to accept gifts and donations and administer those as they're currently already doing.
Any further questions?
Seeing none, thank you for your testimony.
Thank you.
Anybody else wish to testify for or against House Bill 1189?
Seeing none, I'm closing the public hearing on House Bill 1189.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm going to open the hearing on House Bill 1228 relative to the recommendations of the Joint Committee on Dedicated Funds.
I don't have any pink cards.
You can provide them.
Oh, we do.
We do.
Okay, Representative Major.
And there was a handout that was handed out, this document here.
I'm representing non-major from Rockingham district 14 representing the towns of Atkinson and Plasto I was the prime sponsor on hospital 122828, FN, relative to the recommendations of a joint committee on dedicated funds.
Joint committee on dedicated funds meets every year.
And each year we review one-third of all the dedicated funds that dedicated funds is over 300 of them a lot of these funds never get used they probably were used 10 years ago but the last few years haven't been used so we take the agencies associated with this and we look and you can tell if you go to page two Starting on line 10 all the way to the end of page 3 you can see in the first year we review the dedicated funds associated with the Department of Safety police standards and training council Department of Employment Security Department of Business and Economic Affairs and Department of State and this is what we reviewed last year the next year of a five-year cycle I'm not going to read them all we review another group of agencies and we go on for five years and then we started all over again when we review these agencies we asked the agency head he's number one do you have any dedicated funds with no activity over the last two years and do you agree it should be eliminated or why should it not be eliminated?
We go through and we'll end up some of them that have had no activity such as the fund for the denuclearization of nuclear power station that money is in there so when they do turn it off and they can use it to depower whatever they do so we'll keep that fun so as a result of reviewing of these five agencies if you go to the first page of the bill section one it repeals five different dedicated funds and that's associated with the division of motor vehicles.
Do you have any questions on any of them?
Fine.
And section two, make some changes in the amendments associated with dedicated funds and when you sometimes we find a dedicated fund doing something it's not spelled out and we need to fix that by an amendment or when we get rid of a dedicated fund we also need to check the amendments that need to be deleted also so that's essentially in section two section three is associated with the department of business and economic Affairs.
Four.
business and economic affairs for is also associated with that and there's a job grant fund is repealed section 5 repeals funds and also funds associated division of economic development.
Seven is associated with the division of economic development.
Eight is the driver's license fee fund.
9 has to do with the privilege license fund and then the rest of the bill has to do the general fund that means there's nothing otherwise it would have gone to the general fund it's It's like on the uninsured mortars fund, $144,000.
So that will go to the general fund.
A follow-up question, Mr.
Chairman.
So I guess what I'm trying to look at is, does the state have any other fund that is dealing with promotion outside the country, or is that Representative Almi's expertise area?
Yes, they do.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Chairman.
Any other questions?
Let me just add to that.
This was agreed to by the commissioner of this particular agency.
Any other questions of Representative Major Sinan?
Thank you very much.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Representative Ames.
I just wanted to first thank you and Representative Almi for some very hard work.
I know this is tedious stuff, but it's really important, so it's appreciated.
And then I think what's involved here is getting to a level of confidence that a particular fund is inactive and needs to be closed out.
And you go through a process, this is my understanding of review, it starts with there's no activity in a fund.
And then you ask questions and you go through a process.
And in the end, you have a bill, which we have in front of us.
And even at this point, it's part of the process of assuring oneself, government, that this is indeed the end of the line for this fund, and it should be.
And so we have this process, and I think, as I recall, looking back over the many years that you've been working on this, that on rare occasions there has been new information that has come forward.
So that's part of the process, and then we reach closure.
Is that an accurate way of describing it?
So at the end of that closure, we have a high degree of confidence that we're not taking money out of a place where maybe next year it will really be needed.
Right.
We go through this process, and even right up to the last moment, if somebody out there feels that this fund needs to be kept, it gives them an opportunity to come and give us a reason of why.
And that's happened a few times.
But over the years, at least the five years now, we we probably eliminated like about 80 funds that were in existence that well again I thank you so much for doing this I just want to point out that this is a joint committee so it's addition to Representative Major and Almey, there's Representative Edwards and Umberger, and then Senator Gaida and Senator Gray on this that have been working on this, and then the alternates are Senator D'Alessandro and Representative Leishman.
So I guess we should thank them all for their hard work on this.
Thank you.
Representative Almey, do you want to say a few words?
I'm Representative Susan Alamey, City of Lebanon.
When we started working on these funds, it was me and the LBAO.
There were a lot of funds that the agencies didn't know they were in charge of.
There were a number of funds that had not had money or were still holding money that had not been used for decades.
And it's been a very long process of getting all of these funds discovered.
We're still occasionally discovering something in the state government and getting them out in the open in what I call a telephone book.
It's a listing of everything.
It's now online.
It's now easy to find.
They hid it for several years because it was complicated and people were going to ask them questions.
So, and then we created this committee.
Before that, we were having a really hard time getting the heads of committees to pay attention to the funds that we had declared were in their interest area.
This committee has got, as you said, people from finance on it in both House and Senate as well as us.
The finance people, not the ultimate so much, but have actually been showing up and feel like they've learned something from it because the finance people in the budget do not pay much attention to dedicated funds.
There are too many of them.
It takes too long.
They've got too much to do with the general budget.
So this has been very valuable for us.
It's a five-year rotating scheme.
We are finally back in the first year.
We didn't do the first year very well in the beginning, and we've been learning over time, but I think we've got it down now.
And I just wanted to take you very quickly through these items.
The first two repeals are something that we looked at safety and we said to them, why are these dedicated funds?
They have no money.
And they said, oh yeah, we just moved the money straight over to the parts of the budget that need it.
We don't put it through these funds.
So we said, can we get rid of these?
And they said, said yes that is the state jobs grant fund this committee in 2005 the state budget included an item for co-host and Sullivan counties to help them develop jobs it was due to expire in 2009, and it came to our committee, and we modified it a little and recognized the fact that Sullivan had spent all of their side of the money, and COAS hadn't done anything yet.
And we gave them, I think, until the money would run out.
It was $800,000 originally.
And it was still there.
It hadn't been used at all for at least five years, probably more than that, because it's a little complicated for COAS to use.
Thank you.
for at least five years, probably more than that, because it's a little complicated for co-hosts to use.
And Sullivan had used everything.
It was divided into thirds, and they'd used the middle third as well as their own.
So there's $136,000 that was left in there that had been sitting there.
And Business and Economic Affairs said, we don't, I mean, it's just sitting there.
Let's get rid of it.
We said, yeah, it's about time to get rid of it.
Limited Privilege License Fund was established to pay for the administrative side of special licenses, restricted licenses for DWI offenders so that they could go to their treatment and to work.
and it's a very good program.
Department of Safety loves it.
For a number of years now the Department of Motor Vehicles had decided it couldn't pay the the license amount which is $50 a, was not enough to pay for their administrative costs, so they just included it in their budget.
And what this does is simply to get rid of the $50 fund and recognize that the money has been put into the Department of Motor Vehicles budget.
And because that's part of the highway fund, the money that's in it lapses to the highway fund.
And the last one is another one of several things that Business and Economic Affairs asked us to do.
When dread was divided up, a great deal of chaos was created in cultural and natural resources and in Business and Economic Affairs.
And this is And we worked very hard and got the cultural and natural resources part of it straightened out the year before.
But this year, this was business and economic affairs.
This is a very old program that wasn't doing anything anymore and that is being lapsed into another program that does very closely related stuff.
Both of them are paid for by business contributions.
And so that essentially is what we did with those.
Another piece of this, the International Trade Promotion Fund, is still in existence.
on it, when it was created, the language which was still existing says, the monies in this fund shall be non-lapsing.
Somebody had been lapsing the money every year.
So we talked it over with the comptroller, we talked it over with BEA, and we decided that the finance people actually on the committee decided that let's just say that it lapses.
And it's zero because we're just doing what the current practice is and that occurs occasionally fairly often so that I think is all of them and it's easier to get through them than it was last year because we were doing two years at a time.
Thank you, Representative.
I'll meet.
Representative Horrigan, did you fill out a print card?
Yes.
Okay.
Watch the wires.
Watch the wires watch the wires watch the wires okay I'm going to open the public hearing on House Bill 1509, an act relative to the termination of the FRM Victims Contribution Recovery Fund.
This is sponsored by Representative Horrigan.
Representative Horrigan, it's filled out a pink card in support of the bill.
And Representative Horrigan introduced House Bill 1509.
Thank you very much.
My name is Representative Horrigan.
I represent the director of the District 6.
House of Syrup and Massbury.
Colled date.
Are we going to hear anything from the Attorney General?
Thank you.
And if I could ask just one question to Representative Horrigan.
Yes.
Thank you.
have you read or been able to get to the part of our laws which Thank you.
Have you read or been able to get to the part of our laws, which is in case law or whatever you call that section that we aren't allowed to look at because our laws were sold by Acts the Tax long ago?
on 216, 293, 4 to 5, relative to the disposition of funds in the victim.
That particular thing, if it dated back to the Mel Thompson era, I probably would not have seen it yet.
I had a relatively short amount of time to research this because I was involved with other things, and then I didn't know this hearing was coming up today until like January 7th.
Anyway, yes, whatever it is is probably worth looking at.
So the LBAO has the chapter law in its office, and we ought to be able to get a copy of whatever this is for the committee as well as talking to the Attorney General's office yes thank you representing early thank you mr.
Church thank you for taking my question representative um listening to your presentation and in reading this bill I'm a little confused and I hope you can give me a succinct answer to this question.
Do you believe that the state or the state bureaucracy has no liability because of the bureaucracy of the agency's myths and malfeasance involved with the fraud that was perpetrated on its citizens?
Well, they were not the ones who perpetrated the fraud.
There's certainly, as I said, a lot of blame to go around.
I don't think the taxpayers automatically have a claim against people who were victimized by these schemes.
So no, but I, and of course the bureaucracy is what it is because to a large extent because we wanted it that way.
We wanted minimal regulation and certainly Farrah and Dodge and the others, they certainly did design it to fall through the cracks of the existing system.
So I'm not sure whether we necessarily owe these individuals the $10 million.
I mean, there were certainly a lot of ridiculous things going on.
Like, for example, they had many complaints to the Attorney General's Office of Computer Fraud Hotline, which was, I think, staffed entirely by retirees.
So it's basically just people coming in for a few hours a week to get out of retired people coming in to get out of the house who were basically doing these changes for a cup of coffee and a donut or knowing the state government maybe they didn't even provide the coffee and there was a lot of yes I mean there's a lot of like a lot of things that are wrong with the regulations and then of course it's to change them.
Like we did change RSA 397A, which is the banking regulation law, shortly after, and then we got sued by somebody who was...
Representative Urily has a follow-up.
Okay, thanks.
Maybe I should have just said no, but...
Yeah.
That would have been succinct, Representative.
Yeah, you did ask me to be succinct tonight.
You're aware, however, that there was a resignation by the commissioner of the banking division because his division didn't do its job, and you're aware of the difficulties within the AG's department because the AG didn't do its job and then foisted it over to the federal banks for their operations.
And you're aware that it didn't, that there was an active element to excuse the acronym CYA on the part of the agencies.
So, I'm...
Well, it was a mess.
I know about that.
I know about, I'm familiar, familiar with a lot of it.
Thank you, Representative.
I appreciate you acknowledging that.
Any further questions?
Seeing none, thank you for your testimony, Representative Horrigan.
Next, we have Representative Hobson followed by Representative Silver.
And Representative Hobson is testifying to oppose the bill.
Thank you, Chair Major, and thank you, honorable colleagues.
I am here today to read some testimony from Ken Wyler, and I believe that it's important to read this so that the viewers at home who are watching this on livestream can hear Representative Wyler's viewpoint.
So this comes direct from Rep.
Wyler.
Number one, the FRM scandal was unique in New Hampshire government for its size and the cover-up by leaders in at least two agencies.
The losses were around $30 million.
The commissioner, number two, I'm sorry, the commissioner of the banking division was forced to retire, and the attorney general for the consumer affairs division was let go.
number three I bring two copies of the third investigative report from November 30, 2011.
It details the findings of the committee, and while we decided that the cover-up, there is a book with the title Cover-Up, written by Mark Conley, past director of securities, as Rep.
Horrigan mentioned, was so egregious that the state rightly owed some small portion of the investor's losses from state funds.
If any other member wishes to have a copy, please email Ken Weiler at kweiler at AOL.com.
This payment, number four, this payment has a long history.
We decided on $10 million, but in several other budget bills, that amount was looked at as low-hanging fruit that some other group grabbed to bring some other program in balance.
Number five, about six years ago, we were able to put into the forms and methods whereby the AG's office would determine the awards.
Number six, in the House version this past year, I devised sources of money that could not be used elsewhere.
The Senate had surpluses and changed to general funds.
Number seven, the AG Charitable Trust Division has begun the application of the distribution to the victims.
This would be a very poor time to bring this legislation forward.
The victims of the FRM Ponzi scheme have been victimized at least three times.
First by the FRM scheme enabled by false statements by the banking division and the AG.
Next, by the AG turning the case over to federal bankruptcy court.
Thirdly, by the federally appointed trustee who browbeat some remaining funds from the investors to pad his own fees.
Do not let an additional attempt to defraud these victims occur.
There is no reason for this bill.
It is wrongheaded and vindictive.
Please make this HB 1509 inexpedient to legislate.
The argument as to making victims quote whole unquote is false.
The equation for this fund is the amount lost minus the totals of the interest accrued and any and all funds received from the Thank you.
and this was testimony by Representative Weiler.
Yep, and you should all have a copy, and I've asked him to forward it digitally through email.
So thank you for listening.
Will you take any questions?
I'm sorry, I'm not prepared for questions.
Thank you.
I bring two copies of the third investigative report that's in the testimony.
Are those two copies provided?
Do we have them?
Yes, they are.
We have hard copy, and I think it says if you want to email Ken Weiler to get a copy of this, you can.
Maybe we could make hard copies for all members.
Is it long?
We'll make hard copies.
No, it's a short report.
No, it is very short, and I think that further testifiers will have some information to answer your questions.
Thank you.
Representatives Silber.
Testifying in opposition to the bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and colleagues.
First of all, I'm Norman Silber, a state representative from Belknap County District 2, the towns of Guilford and Meredith, Meredith being the epicenter of the FRM scandal.
As a side note, I am not wearing a mask this morning because I had COVID last year and successfully recovered from it.
So my doctor says I have a lot of high national immunity.
A hundred years ago or so, anybody who wanted to open a bank could just hang out a shingle saying at XYZ Bank and people would put their money in there, and when the monies disappeared, there was no recourse.
So the government, federal and state, established funds to repay depositors for lost monies.
Similarly, a hundred and some odd years ago, if you wanted to have a Ponzi scheme involving securities, unless you got caught, you basically there was almost no recourse and so the federal and state government established extensive regulatory schemes to protect investors in securities and there are recovery funds.
For example, the Securities Investor Protection Corporation has a fund, the FDIC and banking has a fund, etc.
And both the SEC and the securities area, the comptroller of the currency and the FDIC all do extensive examinations of these highly regulated industries.
Now we move to FRM, which was supposedly a mortgage investment operation.
Many of you probably know some of the sordid history.
Some of you relatively new may not know the sordid history but obviously it was it turned out a Ponzi scheme where people's monies later investors monies was used to pay off initial or earlier investors and there were actually little or no actual investments in real estate mortgages which was the purpose of the scheme supposedly.
So some people a couple of people other promoters went to jail.
Now who were the investors in FRM?
Were they big companies?
Were they big rich investors?, I think, uniformly is no.
The investors, for the most part, while not exclusively centered in my county, Belknap County, but certainly most of them were from Belknap County, were hardworking individuals who had accumulated some funds at a time when banks were paying little or no interest on funds.
And they were induced to invest with the promise that they were going to get a secure investment with a decent rate of return.
And of course it didn't turn out that way.
It turned out that they lost their money.
People who know me in my politics for the two terms I've been in the legislature know that I am probably the last person in the legislature to advocate giving away taxpayer money.
I am a low tax guy.
But it seems to me that when you are dealing with a highly regulated industry, which is what mortgage banking is supposed to be in our state and you have several agencies involved in that regulation and those agencies fail the taxpayers many times because there were many opportunities for them to have caught the scheme early on and prevented the level of losses and there are reports and I don't know if they're true or not, that there were relatives of one of the heads of one of our state departments were actually investors, equity investors in FRM.
So the only people that went to jail were the people who were the actual promoters.
But we had people in the banking department and we had people in the attorney general's office who completely ignored and not only ignored their obligation to the taxpayers to regulate and to call a halt to any fraudulent schemes, but when asked by prospective investors to these agencies, they were reassured that FRM was sound, notwithstanding the fact that there were approximately 70 indicia over the years that fraud was taking place.
So my view is that when the government has utterly failed our citizenry, who paid taxes in the expectation that a regulated industry is going to be properly regulated, that if we have the ability to provide for some sort of recompense, and let's talk about the numbers, five and five.
Those numbers have been kicked around by the state senate and by the house for years.
And we finally ended up with a proposal in the budget bill passed by the house and the senate to fund this fund, this recompense fund.
What does it give you, what does it give people back?
Does it make them whole?
Not by a long shot.
It makes gives them a slight percentage of what they've lost in recovery.
I personally know constituents and members of this general court who were investors who had to go through personal bankruptcy as a result of losses through the FRM scandal, which the state failed our citizens.
So that's why I believe that we were able to pass finally, after many years of talking and discussion and debate, in the House and the Senate and in the budget bill this fund, which gives a nominal amount of...
and discussion and debate in the House and the Senate and in the budget bill, this fund, which gives a nominal amount of recovery to the investors.
I recommend that the committee vote this bill in expedient to legislate.
Thank you for your testimony, Representative.
Would you take questions?
Absolutely.
Representative Almey followed by Representative Bromney.
I may have to give you lawyerly answers.
That's okay.
I've been around here a long time and i can't remember when this started to break but i wanted to ask you because you probably know the answer to this on at the time what they were talking about was that the Finance Committee had decided to reorganize the responsibilities of the Banking Commission, the Securities Division, in the Secretary of State's office, which also was tangled into this as one of the people who might have made it worse, and the Attorney General's office, and that they left out some responsibilities when they reorganized them, and that the agencies, it was the legislature somewhat more than the agencies that created this problem.
Do you, had you heard anything like that?
What I have heard is that the Securities Division was the only state agency that seemed to be not asleep at the switch.
That the Banking Department and the Attorney General's office were not only asleep at the switch, but in fact facil the fraud by their some of their answers to inquiries by prospective investors.
So I don't know what reorganization was done.
Keep in mind that the members, the staff, unless they have committed an actual criminal act, are going to be immune under sovereign immunity.
So while I might have a personal view as to what some of the folks in the AG's office and the banking department, where they should be playing tennis in some fed somewhere, and they're not, that can't happen, and that didn't happen.
So I don't know what happened other than the fact that I have been told by people who were intimately involved that the securities division were the only people who seemed to know what was going on.
I don't know if that answers your question.
Gives me a second perspective.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
So I think he answered the question about is there any additional money in the fund because it sounds like this is the first budget that we're funding this.
Is that correct?
Correct.
Yes.
So what does the $10 million do?
What percent of the, well, first off, do we know how many folks will actually request money from this fund?
The answer is we do not know how many.
Historically, in cases like this or in class actions, which are very similar, and they establish a recovery fund, if you get a 60% application rate, 60% to 70% rate, that's probably high.
So 20% to 30% of people just say, you know, I've lost the money and they walk away.
So we don't know that's number one.
And number two, we don't know the percentage because it's done pro rata, but it's going to be somewhere in 20% to 30% of their out-of One more follow up.
Follow up.
So would you say that, depending how many people actually apply over the next two years, really, what are the chances of the legislature approving additional money?
Do you think that's necessary, first off, and do you know if that will happen in the next biennium?
Some might think it would be necessary, but I would not be in favor of it.
Thank you.
Representative Yule.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, fellow survivor.
Although you seem to have made out better than I did, but that's okay.
I have two questions, if don't mind Mr.
Chair quickly uh the first one is a real simple one and I think you kind of answered it but I just want to hear a really short answer so is it your opinion personally that the current bill is a process to make the investors whole?
The budget bill that was passed gives the investors partial recovery.
The existing bill removes any chance of recovery.
This bill we're hearing today wipes that out.
And just to be fair, so I'll ask you the same question I asked the previous representative.
Do you believe the state has any liability for the bureaucratic myths and malfeasance that has been clearly demonstrated with regards to the investors?
I'll give you the lawyerly answer.
No, I want a yes or no.
There is no legal liability, but there is certainly moral liability.
Thank you, sir.
Further questions?
Rep.
Schoenberg.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Representative, for taking my question.
The FRM Victims Contribution Recovery Fund that was in the budget bill, was that ever presented to a New Hampshire State House committee as a form of a bill for public discussion this past legislative session?
I believe it was, along with many other so-called policy bills, and they were then passed to the Senate, and the Senate adopted them, and then they were all folded into the budget bill in that cluster, whatever we were doing to throw so much stuff into the budget bill.
But I do believe it was heard by both Senate and House committees.
Follow-up question, Mr.
Chairman.
Follow-up.
Would you be able to get the House committee that did hear that bill?
I will endeavor to do so.
Thank you, sir.
Appreciate it.
Further questions?
Representative Gamalo.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
What I understood from the sponsor of the bill was that this act comes into effect July 1 of 2023, in essence giving victims two years to access the $10 million.
Is that correct or incorrect?
I'm not that familiar with the intricacies of the procedure to follow for applying for recovery.
I can't say that I know that.
Further questions?
Thank you.
I see none, so thank you for your testimony.
I see none so thank you for your testimony thank you, thank you colleagues anybody else wish to testify for or against House Bill 1509 Mr.
Chair Mr.
Chair, over here I just want to underscore and repeat that we really need to hear from the Attorney General's office on the status of the administration of this responsibility.
I certainly agree.
Mr.
Chair.
Representative Hogan.
I just have some.
Representative Hobson mentioned the Weiler report, and I printed it up and left that one at home, but I've got several other printouts here.
I mean, research staff will take up all this stuff pretty shortly anyway, but would you like me to leave this with the clerk and they can put it in the bill file like these extra copies of it sure Yeah, yeah the Wiley report I looked at he was on a committee I think it was in 2013 and I have looked at it, but I fortunately did not bring that copy of it although apparently anyway Thank you On the blue sheet, Jennifer.
Thank you.
What'd she say?
There are some.
She should read the names.
Yes.
Can you read the names?
Okay.
Representative Silver, again.
Representative Mary Beth Wall, in support, and Representative Beth Poppins.
Excuse me.
Anybody else wish to testify for or against?
I close the public hearing.
Thank you.
This one?
Or this one?
Yeah.
You know, I was just upstairs in science, energy, and technology, and they, too, were like, oh, well, that box five minutes fast.
So it's like you need to know which room you're in.
I will do it.
You want me to do it?
Sure.
Yeah.
All right.
It's 1113 right now.
Yeah.
The satellite says.
Thank you.
It's 1113 right now.
.
Thank you.
I'll be passing.
Okay.
You're not wrong.
I have the same problem with my fluid, just not being able to keep my windshield clean.
I'm wondering if it's a little.
Well, once again, but the light is for, it releases other stuff.
Yeah.
And it's coming out of a couple of stops when it came out.
The rows are not great.
Yup.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm going to open the public hearing on House Bill 1524FN, an act establishing a National Service Alumni Attraction and Retention Fund.
I just want to remind everybody that this hearing has been live streamed to the public the prime sponsor the bill is representing realm and he's here to testify.
Representative Walton.
Thank you, Chairman.
Chairman Major, members of the House Ways and Means Committee, for the record, my name is Matt Wilhelm.
I proudly represent Hillsborough County District 42, covering Manchester Wards 1, 2, and 3 in the New Hampshire House.
I also serve as the House appointee to the Board of Volunteer New Hampshire.
It's our state's service commission.
Volunteer New Hampshire is a granted states partner to the federal agency AmeriCorps which works with local and national partners to tap the power of the American people to tackle our country's most pressing challenges through national and community service.
Colleagues I'm here today today to introduce House Bill 1524 to establish a National Service Alumni Attraction and Retention Fund.
It's the first of its kind anywhere in the country.
It would set aside American Rescue Plans Act funding to be made available to colleges and universities and employers across the state as scholarships and bonuses for National Service alumni from all across the country, showing that New Hampshire really values the experience of civilian national service, individuals who have served on diverse teams, worked under pressure, and solved problems.
First, a little bit of background on AmeriCorps.
In 2020, more than 2,500 Americans of all ages and backgrounds united to meet local needs, strengthen communities, and expand opportunity through national service in New Hampshire.
AmeriCorps invested more than $6.6 million in federal funding to support cost-effective community solutions, working hand-in-hand with local partners to empower individuals to help communities tackle their toughest challenges.
AmeriCorps members are preparing today's students for tomorrow's jobs.
They're helping communities and families impacted by COVID-19.
They're reducing crime and reviving cities.
They're connecting veterans to services.
They're fighting to end the opioid epidemic.
They're helping seniors live independently, and they're rebuilding communities after disasters.
AmeriCorps members served at more than 300 locations across New Hampshire, very likely in many of your districts, including schools, food banks, homeless shelters, health clinics, youth centers, veterans facilities, and other non-profit and faith-based organizations.
AmeriCorps and its partners generated more than $5.7 million in outside resources from businesses, foundations, public agencies, and other sources in New Hampshire in 2020.
This local support strengthened community impact and increased the return on taxpayer dollars.
A recent study by ICF commissioned by Voices for National Service and funded by the Charles Stewart Mott Foundation found that national service programs that leverage the skills and to address unmet community needs, they offer substantial monetary benefits for all stakeholder groups and a significant return on investment.
Economists report that for every dollar that Congress appropriates to AmeriCorps, it returns more than $17 to society, program members, and the government.
Personally, AmeriCorps is where I got my start in public service.
It was my first job after graduating from Plymouth State College as a team leader with City or New Hampshire, training and supporting a diverse team of young adults from all across the country, from all different backgrounds and walks of life, who came together to serve as AmeriCorps National Service members in some of our state's highest need and most under-resourced public schools.
We served as full-time tutors, mentors, and role models, all for a modest living stipend, an education award equal to the Pell Grant, which I used to pay back some of my student loans.
That experience really changed my life.
It was my very first job, and it was the very best job that I've ever had, and it started me down a career path of public service.
I'm originally from New Hampshire.
I grew up in Nashua, went to college in Plymouth, served on the seacoast, and put down roots in Manchester.
My wife Jody is also an AmeriCorps alum, originally from New Jersey, so she's a transplant, and we're raising two future AmeriCorps members, our eight-year-old Ben and six-year-old Rosie.
Some of our family's best friends came to New Hampshire from all across the country to do their service year in New Hampshire and we love that they stayed however for each of them there are hundreds who pack up after their service here and put New Hampshire in their rearview mirror permanently each taking with them their Segal AmeriCorps Education Award valued at around $7,000.
And they take with them also their skills in high-demand fields like education and health care that our state so desperately needs.
So that's why when I was first elected to the legislature in 2018, I wanted to figure out how to leverage the proven power and the unrealized potential of civilian national service to address New Hampshire's brain drain in order to attract and retain more community-minded and service-driven AmeriCorps alumni and returned Peace Corps volunteers for an affordable degree or credential and a meaningful career in our state.
So my first bill as a state rep established a National Service Workforce Pathways Commission.
It's a bipartisan bill passed unanimously through both the House and the Senate on the consent calendar in both chambers, was enthusiastically signed into law by Governor Sununu.
I chaired that commission, which included leaders from across sectors, and we came up with recommendations, two of which are included in the bill before you today.
Recommendation number two is within the the Service Year Workforce Commission recommendations is to strengthen existing and establish new pathways from AmeriCorps and the Peace Corps to post-secondary education including increasing the number of public and private institutions of higher education that participate in the Siegel AmeriCorps Education Award matching program, which has since been rebranded as AmeriCorps Schools of Service, as well as the Paul D.
Coverdell Fellows Program for returned Peace Corps volunteers, and that's a graduate school program.
Recommendation number three from our commission was to strengthen existing and establish new pathways from AmeriCorps and the Peace Corps to employment in New Hampshire, including increasing the number of companies, non-profit organizations, and government agencies that participate in the Employers of National Service program for National Service alumni.
So House Bill 1524, it establishes a national service alumni attraction and retention fund, really to provide a carrot for New Hampshire employers and institutions of higher ed to join these nationally recognized programs.
By growing our state's participation in these programs, we can make New Hampshire the top post-service destination for AmeriCorps alumni and returned Peace Corps volunteers, and it can make a real dent in our state's brain drain and workforce challenges.
Funded by the American Rescue Plan Act and administered by Volunteer New Hampshire and the State Department of Administrative Services, it would grant to enrolled employers of national service, sorry, grants to enrolled employers of national service could be set up as a one-for-one, dollar-for-dollar match for employers, offering sign-on and or annual bonuses to AmeriCorps alumni and returned Peace Corps volunteers.
And grants to enrolled schools of service and Coverdell Fellows institutions could be set up as one to one to one match for colleges where students could use their federal education award college match and the National Service Alumni Attraction and Retention Fund to match as well with the high cost of higher education in the state of New, I think it would go a long way to get colleges to come to the table to say, we're going to put some skin in the game.
We know that the young person who wants to get their education here has some skin in the game.
The education award that they earned during their year of service and then for the state to be able to match that with ARPA funds could go a long way.
So by leveraging federal funding and at no additional cost to New Hampshire taxpayers, we have an opportunity to make New Hampshire stand out as a destination for hardworking young Americans to not only pursue national and community service, but also stay for an affordable college degree or credential and a meaningful career, especially in high-demand public service jobs like health care and education so colleagues I urge you to adopt a bipartisan ought to pass recommendation hearing committee and I welcome your questions thank you for your testimony represent Romney thank you Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you for being here.
So let's start with the American Rescue Plan funds.
I know in Rockingham County, I was involved in coming up with the plan to spend the funds, the $60 million that Rockingham got.
So all that money is obligated.
So are you saying that there's still money not obligated that went to the state of New Hampshire that's still available to put into this?
That's my understanding, yes.
Okay.
Because that's an important piece of this, that there's money left to, and what this bill is going to direct some of that money.
My understanding is the committee that's looking at this.
Maybe the chair can help me out with that.
But okay, so I just want to understand that.
But this money isn't forever.
So what happens?
Sorry, Mr.
Chair, follow up.
This money isn't forever.
So how do we replace that money in future years once this rescue plan money goes away?
Thank you, Representative, for the question.
I, you know, this, in many ways, I look at as a pilot program.
These are one-time funds that are available to the state of New Hampshire that could be allocated for this workforce development purpose.
You know, I think we need to evaluate the program like we would any program.
And if this is something that the state wanted to continue, if they felt like it was a good return on investment, if there were other federal funds that could be used to support that program in the future, I think that's a conversation that can happen down the line.
But I think it would be important to make clear with the launch of the program to employers and to institutions of higher ed that this is one-time money that's available for a limited time.
But I think what it does, this invests in these programs that are so important and that have been underutilized by employers and colleges and universities in the state up until now I've got a list I could tell you what the colleges and universities that have already signed up for you know to match these education awards that these young people get when they finish their year of service and employers that say hey you know anything from we'll guarantee you a job interview if you've done a year of service.
There are a few other things that they can do to qualify for the program.
But what it would allow the state of New Hampshire to do, it's kind of the carrot to encourage these organizations to provide some additional incentives to young people as they're trying to figure out what they want to do with their lives.
And hopefully hopefully encourage some of them to do a year of service.
So there's no specific dollar amount in the bill in terms of what you'd like to see from the American Rescue Plan.
Is it if we pass this, then you would have to argue your point?
Is that the strategy?
Then after this is passed, that you would have to argue with others for that American Rescue Fund money?
Yeah.
I mean, my understanding is that if this comes to this committee first, goes to the floor, passes the floor, it will get kicked over to fiscal, and we would need to have a conversation about it.
Yeah, because, again, there's no amount here that you're going to be requesting.
So, okay, thank you.
You're welcome.
For other questions, Representative Almey.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
First, I wanted to just confirm with you on the structure of Volunteer New Hampshire.
There is a board of directors, an executive director.
They're administratively attached to DAS.
That's correct.
That's true?
Thank you.
And then I wanted to ask, you specifically state in the bill, the commissioner, who is DAS, shall credit all state funds received from the American Rescue Plan for the purpose of this subdivision to the fund.
That is, you know that there is in the American Rescue Plan a section which is funding for something that is covered by this yes and all of that money according to this bill would go there well and perhaps we need to adjust it thank you for the question representative i think you know there needs to be a specific amount i mean the way the bill is drafted there is is no specific amount that is allocated to this fund.
And so what I'm hearing from committees is that it's going to be important to clarify what that is and how much money is in there so that it's not all ARPA funds that are accredited to the state of New Hampshire for workforce development, let's say, go to this program do you know sorry do you know where where we would get that information from I can double check or the chair can double check who we need to talk to to find out how much money we're talking about because if it's $50,000 a year and it costs $42,000 to administer it in DAS, we've got a problem.
Right.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Other questions?
Representative Brown.
More clarifying.
Thank you, Representative Almey.
I missed that.
They're asking for the money that's allocated and the American Rescue Plan is a certain amount that you can allocate.
And I agree.
We need to know what that is.
Not leave it to finance.
Right.
So OK.
Well, that clarifies my thinking.
I just want to make that statement.
Thank you for that.
Great.
Thank you.
Further questions.
I see no further questions.
So thank you.
Thank you, Chairman.
Anybody else wish to testify for or against House Bill 1524?
Jennifer, nothing on the blue sheet.
So I'm going to close the public hearing on House Bill 1524.
Mr.
Chairman?
Yes.
We do have the ability to sign up in favor or oppose to legislation online still.
I just discovered that yesterday.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, so there's a possibility there would be people for several of these bills.
Thanks.
Mr.
Chair, to clarify what Representative Almey said, I guess you're saying if they're online that we should read them into the record at some point?
Yeah.
Okay.
Jennifer, could you check on that, and then we will read those into the record?
Thank you.
For 50.4 on the line, there are 24 and 24.
Would you like to share any of the other bills for today in the morning?
Right.
Well, if you can get a copy, then we'll read them in this afternoon.
Okay.
Just so you know, these sheets are open until midnight tonight.
Oh.
So they may not be completed.
They'll be completed until then.
Oh, that's great.
The hearing is over.
Okay, I guess we have no choice.
And we'll read them in on Thursday.
People are not, however, allowed to testify that way.
Anything else?
If not, we're on break until 1 o'clock.
Thank you.
So for the audience, this clock is fast, that clock is slow.
We'll go by my clock.
We've got three minutes.
Thank you.
So we're going to call the hearing on House Bill 525 to order.
I just want to announce it for the committee.
Representative Major, some of you may know, he had some car trouble this morning.
His car was overheating, and he got nervous.
And his local car dealer said they're fully booked until next week.
It's amazing.
So he had to scramble and try to find a dealer around here that could help him out.
So he didn't want to be driving in the nighttime with a car problem.
So with that...
Did he buy a new car?
Maybe.
I told him to take his antifreeze.
So the prime sponsor of the bill is Judy Aaron.
Representative Judy Aaron.
We're all getting used to this new sound system and all.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee.
Thank you so much for having me come today to introduce this bill, HB 1525.
I'm introducing this bill to establish a county nursing home capital reserve fund.
Our county nursing homes are valuable and necessary facilities in our state.
We have 11 county nursing homes, two of which are in Coloss County.
While these facilities are not statutorily required, they have long been part of each county's mission to provide health care services to citizens of the county, especially for our elderly population in need of skilled nursing and medical care.
They provide a home and a place for people to receive nursing care that would otherwise be unavailable to them in their own home.
And they are an important health care investment and asset to our municipalities, our counties, and to our state.
With the desire to keep these facilities running and keeping them updated and fully functional for a few counties, we are fast running into maintenance issues and infrastructure as their infrastructure ages out.
When buildings begin to age out, there are issues with basic infrastructure such as electrical, heating, and plumbing.
And when maintenance finally becomes a series of band-aids, then it's time to consider renovations and possibly new construction.
Here's the problem.
The cost of doing these renovations or new construction has become unmanageable for our counties.
Counties can no longer determine their own fate with the changes they wish to make when buildings need updating.
They are at the mercy of federal guidelines, especially the Facilities Guidelines Institute, known as the FGI, which determined for counties the space requirements per resident, as well as for a host of other space requirements for other functions in the facility.
For example, changes from the 2014 to the 2018 version of FGI added 19 square feet to just one bed space, and when you multiply that to how many beds a facility has, it can mount up quickly in cost.
Right now, the requirement is for semi-private rooms where two people may share a room.
You cannot have more people than that, and there are specific requirements for bathroom spaces as well.
So in any renovation, you have to adhere to these space requirements, and they require a number.
The FGI also requires a number of bariatric rooms for obese patients too.
Additionally, it has been noted in a recent preview of their white paper that the next version of FGI will likely require these facilities have private rooms only.
That being said, we have to also take into account inflation and the cost of labor and materials to do the renovations or new builds in accordance with FGI.
So what are counties to do?
They cannot ignore the need for facility upgrades, nor can they continue to put band-aids on infrastructure that's aging out.
They also don't want to cause county taxes to skyrocket and cause a huge tax burden on citizens, especially since the nursing homes are not the only function that counties provide.
They also don't want to close the nursing home facilities because people are in need of care, especially as the baby boomer generation is reaching the age of needing these facilities.
Counties can try and cut renovation or rebuild costs as best, or their rebuild costs as best as possible without compromising quality while adhering to guidelines, but sometimes that just can't be accomplished.
They also can't go cutting down bed space because that can cause further financial damage to the county.
So here you have a need to upgrade facilities conflicting with the taxpayers' ability to pay for a very necessary county function.
This is why counties now need help from the state.
Our counties are at a crossroads.
Those counties who are looking to upgrade their facilities can no longer do so for the sums of money that used to be manageable by the county alone.
The state is in a position to help because of its ability to get grant money from the federal government, as well as income from other sources.
Now, I know this is an off-budget year, and this is a very challenging ask in this bill.
But we also have much ARPA money available to be used to help fund this new capital reserve fund.
And some of that money is destined to be used for upgrading ventilation systems to help mitigate viral transmission and stuff like that.
So this is a natural good use for much of that ARPA funding.
So money from ARPA can be utilized to help with viral infection mitigation infrastructure with these renovations and new builds and the state has an interest in keeping these facilities updated and continuing to provide care for the most vulnerable in our society.
These places are important assets to our state and should be a source of pride.
The bill I present to you today was modeled after the school building aid program already in place in statute.
Establishing a County Nursing Home Capital Reserve Fund administered by DHHS is appropriate since DHHS works alongside these County Nursing Home projects.
They approve plans and make sure the requirements are met and licenses can be kept intact.
They therefore understand the need, the plans, and the cost of any county nursing home renovation or new build project.
They can also help determine how much money the project would be eligible for from a fund, such as this, based on the number of beds and who those beds will serve.
It will be an easy fit for DHHS to administer this fund.
I'm proposing that the state seeds this fund with $25 million by June 30, 2022 and then continue to fund it with an appropriation of $15 million every year after.
There's a $30 million cap that I've put on this.
In addition to DHS applying for any federal grants that may be available and appropriate to be placed into this fund, the point is to have money in this fund to help our counties deal with the escalating costs of upgrading facilities.
We must do this.
We must pass this bill and help our counties deal with the cost of keeping these facilities in good working order and to upgrade with the codes and guidelines.
And otherwise, they will simply close or worse yet, deteriorate into unsafe and horrible places that no one would want to send their loved ones to in their twilight years.
New Hampshire should take an active part in seeing that these facilities are the best they can be and become a partner with our 10 counties to make sure we can continue to have health care for our elderly that we can be proud of.
I also want to add that I'm very proud to see a bipartisan support for this bill.
Everyone should see the importance of making sure that these facilities don't go into ruin.
And with that, I would be happy to entertain any of your questions.
First, I want to make a comment to the committee.
This is a two-committee bill.
We're looking at the whole thing, but we're here looking at the fund, setting up this fund.
That's why it came to Ways and Means.
But then it will be going to finance to address the asks here, the $25 million and then the $15 million thereafter.
So with that, any questions?
Representative Schaumburg.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Representative, for taking my questions.
It's a three-part question, Mr.
Chairman.
Do you know if all the counties have established a capital improvement program by their commissioners?
I would imagine that would be good practice to do so.
I don't know for sure, but I would believe that that's true.
I know Sullivan County, we have a fund that we put money into.
Thank follow up will the CRF be distributed in equal amounts to all county nursing homes for renovation or new construction I notice there's a number on here that has to be at least five million I think, I believe the way I envision this is we have several counties who have already completed renovations.
They may not need money for quite a while.
For those few, one or two, that are looking at doing renovations, they would be discussing their needs with DHHS for funding from this to help them so that they would not have to raise taxes exorbitantly.
Even if the state could kick in $5-10 million to a project, it relieves a huge burden for the taxpayers of the county.
And the third follow-up, on line 14, page 2, you mentioned that the state should maybe seed this CRF with $25 million.
What would be the source, or where would the source of this revenue come from?
Well, I think that we certainly have sufficient funds coming from what we have with ARPA money.
I would imagine we could get that from there.
I've spoken to members of the finance committee ahead of this.
They said there's plenty of money to be had.
So I would see that, you know, as the finance committee could probably figure out where they could get that money from.
Thank you very much for your answers.
Representative Rulery.
Thank you, Mr..
chair thank you for taking my question Hillsborough County capital reserve fund for the nursing home alone somewhere approaching 30 million dollars so would you be taxing the residents of Hillsborough County to fund a nursing home in Coas County?
I, well, if we would be asking the state to put funds aside in this capital reserve fund, I'm not sure where the source of, you know, that funds would be from.
Would be from our taxpayers or fees that are paid from out of state or, you know, that's something I think the finance committee would be able to figure out.
Follow up, Mr.
Chairman.
Would you agree with me that not each county needs the same amount of improvement absolutely Merrimack is brand new Rockingham just redid theirs we just put an addition on down in in Gossetown, a new roof, new air conditioner stuff, and we're still using ARPA funds for that directly.
The counties can apply for ARPA funds directly.
So would you agree with me that having the state duplicate what the counties can already do as constitutional entities may be duplicative, that word?
I wouldn't call them duplicative.
I would call them, you know, that they would be kind of filling a gap that the county can't manage on its own.
The costs of these renovation projects have become so exorbitant that we're finding, and yes, there are some counties that have already done their renovations, and they're fine.
They're good for a bunch of years.
10, 15 years, they wouldn't have to be doing anything.
But there are county nursing homes that are in dire need, especially Sullivan County.
You know, we've got a building that's 90 years old that's not functional anymore.
So we're looking to do a renovation in Sullivan County.
There may be, you know, with Coas County, they may need something in the next two years or three years.
The fact is that we have 11 nursing homes, so it's not like you're going to have 100 or, you 100 or all of them all at once asking for money from this fund.
As these counties come across doing and needing these upgrades and these renovations, they can then apply to, as I said, DHHS is involved in the process anyway, so they would be certainly in touch and in tune with what the needs are for these renovations.
And indeed, if a county already has a substantial capital reserve fund, I would imagine DHHS would take a look at that and say, well, you already have $30 million at your disposal, so you don't need $30 million from us or $10 million from us.
We just want to make up...
I just want the state to help and maybe provide some gap funding to help these counties be able to afford these renovations because they are so exorbitant in cost now.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Ames and then Representative Jude Garion.
Hi, I'm Representative Ames.
So I'm from Cheshire County.
We've just finished building, rebuilding but expanding a very fine nursing home, Maplewood Nursing Home, which five years ago was in bad shape.
Overheated rooms from poor ventilation and all sorts of problems.
I can't even begin to catalog them.
And over a period of time, with the leadership provided by the county commissioners and by the legislative delegation, county administrator, and particularly the nursing home administrator, I should add, a plan was developed to redo this facility.
And now it's happened to the tune of about, well, it's above $30 million.
Representative Gamarlo may have a better number than me.
She's also from Cheshire County.
But above $30 million.
And that's been covered by the taxpayers of the towns in Cheshire County.
So now we've got a very fine, very modern nursing home.
Not as full as it should be because we can't hire staff, but that's a different issue.
and so why would I as a representative of some but that's a different issue and so why would I as a representative of some segment of the taxpayers in Cheshire County support something like this where other counties should be able to we would say devise a way with prudent savings, capital improvement programs, and so forth, a way to do the same thing that we did.
Thank you for your question, Representative Ames.
I am aware of the renovations that Cheshire County made to their nursing home facility, and I commend them for the beautiful job that they did.
I would like to make it known though that if you were to do those renovations now under the current FGI, it would probably cost you 30% more in costs.
And what we're seeing happening is just this escalation.
Sullivan County Nursing Home, we are looking at a $50 million dollar project.
And that kind of renovation, yes, we've put money aside for it.
We've saved for it.
But as these renovation costs escalate with inflation and scarcity of supply, it just becomes a little bit, it's sort of like we're chasing this escalation in costs.
And it's becoming more and more difficult to be able to do, for counties to be able to do these renovations without help.
And so what happens is, how long can you?
Putting band-aids on infrastructure that's failing While you're putting aside money and saving Because what's happening is we're ending up having to take that capital reserve dollars to put towards these band-aids instead of putting them aside to save and Actually do the renovations that need to be done.
And further to your point, if it were to be that Cheshire County Nursing Home was full and needed space for residents, they could probably come up and use space up in Sullivan County.
It's, you know, travel distance would be more, but if the facilities are available, that's where, you know, people may be able to go.
Yeah.
I don't think we're debating the need for the nursing home beds, and it certainly should be a sharing system and I guess I'm wondering if there isn't some way to the extent to which there is an agreement that a fund like this may be needed to have in it a local share requirement or something that ensures that everybody's doing their fair share of what it takes to build or to rebuild or to renovate.
In other words, if the next county, Sullivan, knocks on the door, gets 100% of the cost, yeah, it's a greater cost, but if they got that and the next door county down, Cheshire County, had paid for it all, it seems unfair.
But maybe there's a way of digging into that and ensuring that what we're talking about is a boost from the state rather than the whole thing.
And thank you for that comment because the intention of this is not for the state to pay the entire cost of a renovation or rebuild.
The intention is to help a county fill the gap that they cannot raise taxes for or would find that raising taxes, that there would be a portion of that cost that the state could kick in for, not the entire cost at all.
Representative Janagi and then Representative Ami.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
You said Sullivan County has already put some money aside, and you said it looks like the cost of renovation is about $50 million.
Have you looked into ARPA money, and is the ARPA money plus what you've put aside close to what you would need?
Yeah.
Well, when the county manager comes to give his testimony, he can clarify that.
But, yes a Sullivan County received I believe eight million dollars in ARPA funds which is far less than many other counties received and a good portion of that will be going towards the renovation of the of the nursing home facility but the county itself is very limited as to how much of the you know how much ARPA funding they were able to receive.
And we've put that money alongside with money that we've saved in our own capital reserve funds.
It just isn't going to be enough.
And we're also looking at bonding.
Certainly you want to bond a portion of this too.
But if we were to go out and bond for the whole remaining amount, the county tax rate would just be a huge increase.
Thank you.
Representative Almey.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The thing that worries me about this is that most dedicated funds, which is what you're asking us to talk about, is the trust fund, the dedicated fund for this.
They are funded by some revenue source other than the general fund, which, I mean, if this bill asks for it to come from whatever surplus there is that the governor can find, and we aren't going to be having surpluses in a few years.
When we stop getting the federal money and you've cut the taxes, there are more taxes that are trying to be cut this year as well, that surplus is not going to be there.
So the question is, we've already got an affordable housing commitment of $5 million a year that got put into the budget, which is housing for everybody in the state.
This one is asking for up to $15 million every year.
and it seems like it's going it would require intolerable cuts in a lot of other services which the towns then as usual have to make up with their own services or face the wrath of their constituents it's that's why our property tax keeps rising.
So I just, this is my problem with it, and I'm wondering if you can help me out.
Sure.
Thank you so much for that question.
And what I've done here is I put a cap on this fund of $30 million.
So you would not necessarily have to add $15 million every year after, you know, $25 million to begin with and then $15 million every year.
But if there's $30 million in the fund, you don't have to put any money in.
And being that we have 11 county nursing homes, I don't see that there's going to be requests for money every single year.
Because, you know, if a nursing facility has completed their renovations or their rebuild or whatever, there would be no need for them to ask for money from the fund.
I think it's just for these exorbitant projects that are in process or being contemplated.
And I think we can kind of plan out, based on the number of nursing homes that are gonna be needing some sort of funding in the next 10 years.
But again, I put a cap on this fund so that you don't have to put money in every single year.
Representative Camarlo.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Can you explain how the paragraph beginning at line 28, funds shall be allocated using the long-term care beds in the county?
How does that work?
And is it the existing beds or the beds that would be coming into the new project?
I don't know.
I just don't understand quite how that works.
Well, we wanted to put in some sort of way in which we could establish the amount of money that would be coming to a project.
And it made sense to figure it out by What the long-term beds in that county the count of that is because that kind of gives you a sense of what the need is for that particular project or for the county and so we looked at that as being the long-term beds in the county that are in the nursing home facility.
And if you're licensed for, say, 156 beds, I don't think that you're going to be asking for more money than what you already have license for.
so it just seemed to be sort of a benchmark that we could use to determine how much money a particular project may be able to get from the fund.
And you might...
Our county director of our nursing home may be able to explain that in a little bit more detail as well.
As a follow-up, do you think there might be a need for a cap per county?
Isn't it feasible without some kind of a cap that if one county needed money one year, they could use the whole $30 million?
I suppose we could consider that in this.
Okay.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
I see no hands.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, and I appreciate your consideration on this.
Representative Stapleton.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Chair and Committee.
Walter Stapleton, Sullivan County District 5, Claremont Ward 3.
I'm a co-sponsor and a supporter of this bill, and I've heard from many of our constituents, Sullivan County, Claremont has a large proportion of seniors that are concerned about their future as they age and are going to require more care and in the facility setting like we have at Sullivan County Nursing Home we've been working on this for several years and we've got three facilities one built 1930 another in the 70s and the latest the latest one in the early 90s.
The oldest one in 1930 is no longer usable.
It's out of code, it's out of spec, and it's not suitable.
It's just not suitable for patient occupancy and care.
When we started the project, you know, we were looking at the 20, 30 million dollar field and then comes COVID and all of a sudden building materials are going sky high.
Labor is a shortage, a severe shortage.
And when we've got the re-quote from the contractor, we were up to $54 million.
Now, I understand that there are, you know, it's tough running county nursing homes.
And I understand that most of our nursing homes are having trouble breaking even and some working at deficit.
Sullivan County hasn't got the population that Merrimack does or other counties downstate and the load would otherwise fall onto the taxpayers.
But along with COVID comes also CARES, ARPA and infrastructure and jobs in the work.
And I would suspect that money from ARPA and infrastructure, if and when it can pass and come down, will come to the state, and that is a source of money for this.
And we hope that this bill and the reserve will provide a component, not the whole nut.
We don't anticipate asking for $25 million to relieve the $54 million cost or mitigate it, but a component of it.
And how to measure that?
How about proportionality?
We got 156 bed allocation.
Other counties may have more or less.
how about putting a cap on these in a proportional manner to the bed service allocation.
Constituents have asked me to support the county home rehabilitation, and I haven't got one constituent who was opposed to it.
And as I said, we have a growing senior population, and they're concerned where they're going to be, and they want to stay in the community.
And I suppose this is something that's a concern of seniors all over the state.
And I would suggest that a statewide approach to this with this reserve bill is a good way to get started with it not unlike what we faced with the school adequacy and funding issue yeah I know we've got wealthy or donor towns and we've also got towns and cities in need and so the state stepping in to balance and mitigate those needs and assist is where we're headed with education.
I suggest that with the county homes this is an important component of our society and we need to do similar or the same with that.
Out of the three facilities, as I say, we've only got two that are really functional.
The third one, 1930, is actually going to be demolished because it's only suitable for storage and office space.
And the 1970s unit needs upgrade.
It's under par.
And how would any of us like to go into a facility in our older age that is not adequate or suitable for the proper care of patients the 1992 1990s facility is better shape but it still needs modifications to come up to code and the codes are always changing and they're always getting more stringent the county people here can testify more to that in detail because that's what they're working with every day but I'm asking the committee to consider the wider scope of the options and the needs that we have here this is a state concern concern, not just a local one.
And if we can strengthen nursing homes statewide, sure, I'm looking for Sullivan County because that's what I represent.
But if we can do this on a statewide basis with this particular bill as a starting point, I think we'd be well served to address needs in the future.
And that's all I really can say at this point.
Okay, thank you.
Any questions from members?
I see no questions.
Thank you very much, Representative.
Appreciate it.
I had one more point.
I'm sorry, I lost track.
We talked with the offices of Senator Hassan and Shaheen, and they're working on ARPA and the infrastructure bill.
And in the detail, the infrastructure bill, there wasn't specifically a place for nursing homes and medical infrastructure.
But they were going to work to open that up as they got the working on the bill and refined it more.
So if that can be passed, then we have another source to fund the state in order to administer and to fund this particular reserve account.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, we have one more representative.
Representative Clodier.
Yep, there you are.
I'm going to take my mask off to testify.
So can everybody hear me?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
For the record, I'm State Representative John Cloutier from Sullivan County District 10, which comprises the entire city of Claremont.
And I'm here today to testify in favor and as a co-sponsor of House Bill 1525 establishing a county nursing home capital reserve fund and first of all I want to take applaud Representative Aaron the prime sponsor for initiative in sponsoring this bipartisan bill and I'm very pleased to be a co-sponsor.
As Representative Aaron and Representative Stapleton have alluded to, I mean we've had our problems with Sullivan County.
This is one of the reasons this bill came about, but this bill can benefit the entire state, all of our nursing homes.
And remember we have 11 nursing homes, one for each county in the case of Coas County, two.
And this is a real problem and I sort of liken this bill to what we have the school building aid fund where school building aid fund helps build design facilities for people our citizens who are in the dawn of life this fund if it was established would help our citizens who are in the sunset of their lives.
I I think we all agree we need to take care of our senior citizens.
And I know some of you who may have just had new nursing homes renovated or completed and say, why should I support this?
Because we're being taken care of.
This is for the future.
This benefits us all.
Who knows what can happen down the road, even though you may have built a new facility.
Who knows, maybe a bad storm hurricane could devastate your nursing home, and you may need help.
Or you may want to build, because of demand, a larger facility, either an addition or even a separate facility.
This bill I'd foreseen as maybe help in the future.
So it would all county nursing homes not just Sullivan County but we've had our struggles in Sullivan County as delegation chair this term this is and I've been chair several terms the most one of the most divisive issues I've ever ever had to deal with and I see both sides I see the need for a new nursing facility and a lot of my constituents have told me that.
But I also hear from constituents that says we cannot afford this brand new nursing home at a $50 million price tag.
It's unsustainable.
So I'm just, we are working now as a delegation.
We finally came together.
We established a nursing home work group consisting of four members of the delegation and a commissioner to try to work something out.
And we're still undergoing that process.
I've been involved in this for nearly four years when I was first approached about this issue.
This is a serious issue, and we really need some state help with this.
and another thing philosophically, the state doesn't, the counties, excuse me, don't have to establish and run county nursing homes.
It's my understanding, it's optional.
What if all of a sudden our counties got out of the nursing home business?
Where would our people go who maybe need some help, those on Medicaid?
Something would have to happen, and the state would probably have to step in, maybe at a more expensive cost.
So I think we've got to think about this, and we've got to help our counties, a lot of whom are, I can't speak for all counties, but I know Sullivan, among others, and maybe, you know, Coas, and maybe some of the others are struggling.
We need help from the state of New Hampshire, and this is one of the ways we can do it.
And I think it's a reasonable bill.
As far as revenue, right now we've got plenty of revenue.
I know down the road we're going to have to maybe deal with needed revenue, and maybe we need to establish a dedicated fund on this.
Remember, these are our senior citizens.
We're all, you know, if we live long, we're all headed in the same direction.
So I want to be taken care of when I reach that age.
And I know it's very personal to me because I remember as a kid visiting the Sullivan County Nursing Home 60 years ago to visit my great-grandmother.
I remember one of the buildings that is now closed, my great-grandmother was in there, and then she was moved to the Sanders building, which is the main target of this proposed renovation project.
She was one of the first new people in there.
This is very, I expect I'll probably be going there, you know, if nobody can take care of any more, and I can live long enough.
So I really think we've got to do something about our nursing homes and give them a little bit of help.
And I don't think Representative Aaron and the rest of us are asking for very much.
So I hope you'll give this bill 1525 serious consideration and approve it in some form.
Thank you very much.
Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
Representative Cooley, I actually have a question I should have asked earlier.
So the project has to be $5 million or more, is what I read in the bill.
Yeah, that's correct.
It is written.
And so it's not going to, you know, I think that's reasonable fiscally.
It just doesn't fund any sort of facility that costs less than $5 million.
Right, but there's no cap on the grant that can be.
I don't see any limitation on the grant.
Is that something that would come out of rules, something that is going to leave up to HHS to make that decision?
There's no cap.
I can't speculate.
Of course, it may be if you as a committee wanted to amend it to put in some sort of cap or guidelines.
I mean, I would be open.
I can't speak for the rest of the co-sponsors, but I would be open to it in order to get the bill passed.
So I can see your point because you don't want to, you know, we should be careful about spending a lot of money.
We have to be careful.
And if you put in some caps as part of an amendment, I'd be open to it, as I said, but I can't speak for the other co-sponsors.
Okay.
Well, thank you for that answer.
Oh, you're welcome.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Representative Almey.
Thank you.
Do you know this Federal Guidelines Institute, too?
Grafton put in, we put in a new wing of the nursing home, and we turned the oldest wing into administrative offices, and we upgraded the middle wing.
It was extremely painful to have to pay for that, and we all voted at the request of the head of the delegation, who was an engineer and a friend of mine and a very strong Republican.
We all voted to cut the cost down.
Nobody mentioned anything about an FGI, but in fact, we had to pay, I think it was three times what we'd saved in cutting that cost down because we did some very stupid things in the cutting.
And I was just wondering if this Federal Guidelines Institute is a new thing that is overseeing the counties or whether it's been there a long time.
And if anybody is doing anything to try to get them to do cost-benefit analysis as they do this.
Okay, thank you, Representative Almey.
I'm not sure, hopefully there'd be people behind me who will come afterwards who will be able to answer the question better.
I'll admit I am not an expert on that.
I realize there's certain federal guidelines, which I think sometimes are, you know, you'll wonder whether they're worth it.
And so hopefully they would be able to answer that question better because, yes, some of these federal are driving up the cost of nursing homes.
And, of course, it's a real pain.
I mean, I also feel, I don't know, the federal government, if they put in all these mandates, maybe they ought to kick in more money.
But that's an issue we're not in Congress.
We're at the New Hampshire House, of course.
Representative, we have three members in Sutherland County that are going to speak so they may have an answer any follow-up I did if I could just one slightly different question you compared it with the education the the school school building it's a rough building aid and the problem with the school building aid idea was that the richest towns were the ones that could pass the warrant articles and build new buildings.
So we ended up with Salem, for instance, having this palace that I was invited to see once.
and a lot of towns, including mine, until the last minute, not being able to do anything about any of our school buildings.
Okay, I wasn't aware of that, Representative, about the problems with the school building aid fund, so it's something that, considering this bill, I guess you've got to consider the details.
And I don't know, making maybe some suggested language changes.
Of course, I'm always speaking for myself.
I mean, I'm open.
But I think the important thing is to get this nursing home fund created.
And I think the important thing is to get the principle started, to get it started and get it off to a start.
And I mean, I think this bill is for the future.
I mean, maybe the real positive of this are going to be felt years and years after we're all along and gone, at least from this house.
But I think we've got to make, as a state, realize that we have an important investment in all 11 of our county nursing homes.
And I think we'd all like to continue because if the counties, you know, don't stay in the nursing home business, we're probably going to have a lot of problems in this state, frankly, because I don't know who's going to pick up the ball, frankly.
So I'm more than happy, I think, to consult with you.
I think all the rest of the prime sponsor and the co-sponsor are more than willing to work with you on amending this bill.
But the important thing is to iron out the details to get to the principle, I think, which we as all the sponsors want, creation of a capital reserve fund.
So I don't know if I answered your question, but I see your point.
Any other questions?
Oh, yes, Representative Malloy.
I'm sorry.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Representative, for taking my question.
Oh, you're welcome.
And I'm looking at page two, line four, where you talk about adopting the rules pursuant to RSA 541-a.
Okay, this is page 2.
Page 2, line 4, Roman numeral.
Roman, okay.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
That's okay.
I admittedly, I've not read RSA 541-a, how to develop grant application forms, procedure, that kind of thing.
I just would, and there may not be an answer to this, that's fine but I was wondering if in there or if you've talked about this among your group that there's a opportunity for matching grant matching funds to for to move forward and you know prime the pump for some of this money that's all that's all that's all my.
I'm not sure the group.
I mean, I know we have our nursing home working group, so maybe some of the reps that have been involved and commissioners and county may be able to help answer that question.
I assume we're looking at everything as far as matching grants.
In fact, I know one public official encouraged us to do like the hospitals do, establish a capital campaign fund, and I don't know whether we're considering that or not.
We're looking, I think, at everything.
I mean, the federal government, the state government, whatever we can do to help fund our nursing.
And we don't expect, you know, the state and federal government to pick up all the costs.
But I think we need some help, frankly, because the counties are doing the work of the state when it comes to nursing homes and I just feel strongly we need to the state needs to do a little bit more to help them out.
You're welcome.
Any other questions?
Thank you very much.
Okay thank you very much Mr.
Chairman.
I misspoke there were actually four representatives that wanted to speak.
Do you to speak represent Sullivan come on up representative Brian Sullivan Sullivan County District 1 which is Cornish Springfield Plainfield and Grantham.
And speaking to the federal codes that are in place, those actually took effect in 2019.
So partway through the process of designing the renovation, the codes changed.
And at that point, the price went up substantially.
As has been said earlier, when we first started looking at this, we were looking at about $35 million for renovation cost.
When the cost came in at $54 million, that cost was put in front of the delegation and it was voted down overwhelmingly I think there was only one vote in favor of going forward over the course of months that followed two lines of thinking developed one was we've got to find a way to get these costs down because 54 million dollars is outrageous the other line line of thinking is we need to go forward as quickly as possible because the nursing home is in dire need.
Both groups were right.
And however, we struggled mightily with the conflict in the delegation.
eventually we did put together a work group as representative Kludier discussed and I was asked to chair that work group representative Aaron was on that work group as well along with two other reps and a commissioner we did a deep dive into ways in which we could cut costs on this, ways we could change the design.
But due to the constraints put on us by the federal government, we came to the conclusion that in order to maintain what we needed for the county and what our seniors needed from us, there was no practical way to substantially cut the costs so we ended up with the same design moving forward again and we are now waiting for a cost estimate prior to actually going forward with with a bond or a re-bidding of the process so what we were unanimous about I think all along some perhaps didn't believe it but I think we all believed that the nursing home needed to be upgraded we needed to take care of our seniors what we concluded through the process was that there was no practical way of reducing the cost of the project or the scope of the project in a way that would bring the price down substantially in the end we had a unanimous vote of the workgroup to move forward and then we presented to the delegation and we had a unanimous vote of the delegation to move forward with the next step of the process so if there's a question is whether or not we have looked at ways to reducing the cost we're not building the Taj Mahal we're building what our county needs our seniors, according to the codes that are presently in place.
And I would further add that when I moved into Grantham, we built a brand-new house.
I figured we were set, that we were good for life life that was 20 years ago and the renovations are well underway so I would say to counties that have already done a renovation this is not a short-term fund this fund will be there when those renovations get old and need to be redone or when a building needs to be rebuilt.
So this will benefit every county in the state at some point or another, some sooner than others.
And I'll stop there.
I've got a question.
How many beds are we talking about for long-term care?
Is there also rehab beds as well involved?
There are both.
I want to say 156 beds, and some of those beds are dedicated to rehab.
Okay.
I'll ask the folks from the time.
I'll ask.
Okay.
They've got the numbers pinned.
Thank you.
Any questions?
Okay.
I'll ask the folks from the county.
I'll ask.
Okay.
They've got the numbers pinned.
Thank you.
Any questions?
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
We have three representatives from Sullivan County.
We have Mary Bork.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Chair and distinguished members of the committee.
My name name is Mary Burke I'm the director of facilities and operations for Sullivan County and have spent more than 25 years of my professional career in managing facilities and capital improvement projects thank you for the opportunity to appear before you in support of HB 1525 establishing a capital reserve fund to support county-run nursing homes across the state the design construction and renovation of nursing homes is a highly complex and regulated process enforced at the state level by dhhs and at the federal level level by the centers for medicare and medicaid services construction and renovation projects require compliance with current facility Guid guidelines Institute or FGI as we spoke about already with the FGI being the minimum standard for health care facilities to meet it serves as the building code for health care spaces within our nursing homes beyond the FGI nursing homes must also comply with current building codes and regulations.
When I joined Sullivan County in 2017, the county had recently completed a feasibility study to address the outdated building and infrastructure of its nursing home.
As the initial estimates for the project in 2016 were overwhelming, the project moved forward slowly in an effort to evaluate different options with a full design effort for a renovation and addition completed in 2020 from the initial study in 2016 until the final design in 2020 the state of New Hampshire had adopted two new iterations of the FGI in 2000 2014 version and 2018 version as well as a new iteration of the International Building Code or IBC with each new version requirements became more complex and restrictive as FGI moved towards resident centered care with more home-like environments which is an approach very different to the hospital style layouts of nursing home used at the time of construction of many nursing homes in New Hampshire including ours in Sullivan County this layout could not be accommodated within the footburner of our current building compliance that was achievable with a small addition when the project was first initiated in 2016 by 2020 needed a much larger addition at an estimated cost of additional eight million dollars to our project in addition we estimate that in the fall of 2019 when New Hampshire adopted the 2018 IBC and the 2018 FDI our project increased by more than three and a half million for these one-time code changes the new FGI increased the room size again and added even larger rooms to accommodate persons of size the changes increase the average resident room in 2019 by approximately 10% with the next iteration of FGI due to be published in 2022 we can only expect that these codes to become more rigorous when we review the interim guidance published in March of 2021 by FGI in response to the COVID-19 pandemic we can foresee even larger resident rooms an increased number of bathrooms as the code transitions to private rooms because of of funding for the proposed renovation Sullivan County has been in a standstill since 2020 during that time construction costs have continued to rise and we anticipate this delay to have cost Sullivan County nearly six million dollars increased construction costs by the time we hope to rebuild this project later this year the progression of restoring and modernizing the Sullivan County nursing home has ultimately been slowed by the unaffordability of the project to the county the impacts that I have described add up over to 17 million dollars making what would have been a 33 million dollar project in 2016 to what will likely be more than a 50 million dollar project now the cost of delay on such an important project makes it even more unattainable as the next round of code of code changes looms ahead of us New Hampshire counties are charged with caring for some of the most vulnerable citizens in our state it's not only a Sullivan County issue other counties will also be facing needed capital restoration to their aging facilities that no longer provide the safest environment for residents nor allow staff to provide resident-centered care that results in more positive outcomes for our seniors the covid19 pandemic has highlighted seriously serious inadequacies of current buildings and systems where lack of ventilation, shared bathrooms, cramped living spaces for residents, and limited workspace for staff ultimately contribute to the spread of the virus.
While we wait for this project to move forward, we have operated and maintained our facilities in a very reactive mode as systems continue to deteriorate we've had significant failures including sanitary waste piping leaking sewage into occupied office areas flooding of resident rooms with 180 degree water from the heating system leaking steam and water piping failures that flood stairwells with today's supply chain issues we have great concern that major components with our building systems will fail and replacements won't be readily available as we operate in this reactive environment a nursing home capital reserve fund like that for new hampshire school system will ensure the county-run nursing homes can pursue renovation and construction projects in a timely manner and prevent delay of needed improvements to facilities and instruct infrastructure by preventing such delays and deferments this bill supports compliance with the adopted regulations by the state of New Hampshire and supports the mission of New Hampshire counties to provide our elderly residents often with dementia Disabling conditions and no place else to go a safe and comfortable environment Thank you very much for your consideration and I encourage the committee to support HB 1525 I will just make a comment to a question I heard earlier In regards to the bill there is a cap that is proposed on the bill for funding an individual project based on the percentage of the beds in the county so for example in the county in Sullivan County we have 57 percent of the beds in the entire county for nursing homes and so our eligibility for a disbursement out of this fund would be capped at 57% of the total project cost.
Any questions?
I see none.
Representative Almey, you're thinking about it?
Representative Almey.
Yes.
I'm wondering how you decided that that was the significant way to put a cap in.
Because a county that had, for other reasons, a fairly large number of commercial beds would doom its nursing home, which could be full and decaying, as someone pointed out could to not being able to get money from the fund I would have to defer that to the sponsors of the committee I was only offering that fact as in response to a question that I heard go unanswered earlier representative are do you want to answer that question?
Do you have an answer to that question?
Okay, Mr.
Purdy, you're next.
He's next.
Okay, thank you.
Oh, where's that?
I'm sorry.
Sounds like Mr.
Purdy would have an answer to this.
It doesn't say on the card what his position is.
That would be best answered by Mr.
Purdy, and I'm willing to defer my any remaining time that I have for him to speak.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Mr.
Purdy, you're very popular.
I want to hear from you.
Good afternoon Mr.
Chair.
I'm Ted Purdy.
I'm the nursing administrator for Southern accounting health care one question I come up we are our 156 bed facility we're duly certified meaning we can accept Medicare and Medicaid throughout the building currently we have our skilled unit as you allude to is a 20 bed unit our renovations are looking at a 16 bed definitive unit to be able to provide skilled services to the community if I may county nursing homes represent 25% of the licensed beds in New Hampshire Thank you.
to the community if I may county nursing homes represent 25% of the licensed beds in New Hampshire and provide a significant resource to our elderly citizens in care for a greater percentage of Medicaid patients than private facilities the requirements of participation promulgated by the Centers for Medicare and Medicaid services determine the level and quality of services to licensed facilities.
Current requirements and updated life safety and construction codes positively impact the environment of care for our elderly.
The major contributions are to infection control, resident safety, and resident dignity and home-like environment the key components minimizing the spread of infectious diseases including COVID-19 are social distancing and appropriate ventilation the current requirements codify those components spacing between resident beds and furniture along with distances for maneuvering wheelchairs and equipment strengthen the safety of residents and staff when care is provided the requirement to have a bathroom in each of the resident rooms provides for more dignity and personal care is provided along with an enhanced home-like environment county nursing homes are supported by county taxpayers to various degrees primarily due to the high percentage of Medicaid and that the Medicaid does not cover all of our cost smaller counties such as southern co-host Grafton and Cheshire operated a greater percentage of total nursing home beds and thus impact the county tax rate to a larger extent than counties with larger populations for instance as alluded to in Sullivan County we represent 56% of our total beds within the county Coas County with their two facilities represent 47% of beds Grafton County represents 32% Cheshire County represents 29% so it so happens to be that the smaller facilities the smaller counties have a larger impact on the number of beds and also any cost relating to the nursing facility there's not covered by Medicaid Medicare and reimbursement has a larger extent to impact on the taxpayers that I ask for your support of HB 1525.
Who wants to go first?
Representative Almy or Representative Ames?
You have a question.
Representative?
Representative Almy, you want to go first?
Oh, Representative Ames.
You don't have one.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, Representative Gamalo.
Thank you.
So that paragraph that I referenced earlier on page 1, line 28, about the long-term care beds.
So you're talking other facilities in the county that are not county-run and the amount of beds they have and has a percentage of what your facility has is 56 percent.
Correct.
So in Cheshire, we have several Genesis facilities, even in Winchester and other.
Okay.
Now I understand.
Thank you.
I have a question about the 156.
You currently have 156 beds.
Is the project, when the project's done, you're still going to have 156 beds?
Yes.
Okay.
There's no change in the bed number.
No.
Thank you.
How about the mix?
The mix, we traditionally run roughly 85% Medicaid, another 10% private, and the rest Medicare skilled.
I meant a mix of skilled versus nursing home beds.
Right.
And so that's what I was alluding to.
We traditionally run about...
Oh, when you say Medicare, that would be the skill.
Right, Medicare part A.
So usually around 10% to 12% Medicare priority.
Okay.
Thank you.
Okay, Rips.
Thank you, sir.
So of the 156 bed capacity that you currently have, is that fully occupied?
Is it used at that level?
Currently, we've been running on average over the last 10 years about 135, 136 patients.
Uh-huh.
As in all facilities throughout New Hampshire due to COVID and various other aspects, count statewide occupancy is around 70 to 75%.
Yeah, I think that's true in Cheshire County.
Yeah, we've been running currently, we're at 125.
Thank you.
All right, any other questions?
Mr.
Velmi?
Yes, I'm still trying to understand the rationale for your...
Sorry, I'm still trying to understand the rationale for the bills using of the percentage of nursing home beds in the county that are county nursing home beds.
Because it depends a lot on the geography.
In COAS, people just can't get very well.
That's why they have two nursing homes, which are killing them.
But they can't get to places.
And if they live closer to a commercial nursing home, they're going to go to it.
The same thing happens in my county.
I'm continually trying to get people to go to our really good Alzheimer's unit up north but it's an hour up north and the family isn't going to be able to see them very often so they go to Genesis or a couple of other smaller alternatives around.
Is there a question?
The question is, what rationale is there?
And that's what I started with.
So I believe certainly it's part of the sponsors desires to at least recognize the aspect of say Sullivan County in particular co-ops is another one and even Grafton is that is to recognize that our the percentage of total beds is is higher than than it is other statewide so it's a mechanism at least to consider you know what percentage of total beds are provided by Sullivan County and other nursing facilities to help determine would just like nice and we're not supposed to say anything now okay all right any other questions represent packing Phillips thank you thank you mr partyardier, I believe.
I just had a question about the same section that you were just taking a look at of the law.
When it speaks about allocation, the funding allocation for the proportion of beds, the next line says that priorities should be granted to nursing homes with a larger percent of long-term care beds in their facility when compared to other county nursing homes and i guess i just don't understand um the prioritization that's set up here do you have any kind of uh narrative that you can help shed some light about what that priority should be?
I think that there again, the details certainly, we're certainly comfortable with any type of kind of consideration as to how that's done or leave it to Department of Health and Human Services to how it's done.
What we been trying to certainly say into is to indicate that because that the nursing facilities in the smaller counties Sullivan being one has a higher percentage of total beds within the county it impacts and the populations are lower within the counties it impacts the taxpayers to a greater extent when when additional support is needed for the nursing well I think just maybe some clarification and the language might be needed in this section to really get that point across um clearly the folks at ols uh you know are the experts but um i it is um not clear to me in the in this two line section that um you know what your intent or the group's intent is coming across with the language presented so um it might be a little area of refining that's needed thank you okay thank you representative amos i think you Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Representative Ames, I think you had one more.
Yeah, my question was pointed to the same part of this bill.
And it's really both sentences.
The first is the allocation.
Funds shall be allocated as a percentage of the portion.
I don't really understand that.
And then there's the second sentence that you were just discussing, the prioritization.
I think maybe an example to show what the intent is.
If there were indeed $25 million available and more than one project from more than one county with different percentages in the terms described here, what would be the allocation and how would it be prioritized?
I don't have that specific story.
I know you don't, but I'm saying that feedback to us clarifying the intent might lead to some wording changes that would enable all of us to understand it in the same way.
Representative Ames, we do have a representative from HHS here who hasn't submitted a PIN but will answer questions at the end if we need.
Although she said to me she's not really a fiscal person.
But at least she could bring that question back to HHS for us.
All right.
Thank you.
We have one more card, one more gentlemen, I know we're over time, so I will try to be succinct.
We appreciate that.
My name is Derek Furland.
I'm the county manager for Sullivan County.
So thank you very much for the time to hear our testimony today I'll focus on the costs of long-term care there are two components to this cost is the annual operating cost and then the capital cost that we have to incur for major projects so it's important to note there's a representative that mentioned earlier that Hillsborough County has a nursing home reserve fund with over $30 million in it.
Hillsborough County is the only county of the 10 that operates at an annual surplus from their nursing home operations.
Most counties lose anywhere from one and a half to two and a half million dollars a year, as I'm sure you all probably know already.
So that's already a pretty significant investment from each of the county's taxpayers just to maintain the operation and the reason why counties tend to lose money is because the majority of our resident population is supported through the Medicaid program and as we know Medicaid reimbursements do not adequately cover the cost of care.
So in addition to this annual deficit, we now face significant capital costs, which has been articulated as largely being driven by these federal regulations.
Also, the scarcity of labor and demand for materials in more recent years is another significant factor that's increasing these costs.
The projected impact to just Sullivan County if we were to bond for this 50 plus million dollar project would be roughly a 25 percent increase to our current county tax rate.
That would be a pretty big pill to swallow which in fact is the reason why for the past couple of years we've been at basically an impasse because it's just a too big of a pill to swallow.
I think this approach is sensible in terms of what the bill is proposing.
It is Thank you.
past couple of years we've been on a basically an impasse because it's just a too big of a pill to swallow.
I think this approach is sensible in terms of what the bill is proposing.
It is patterned after the state and county or the state collaboration that already exists with the the public education construction fund as we mentioned before.
I think a key difference though is that there are only 11 county nursing homes in the state and I think that the the reality would be that the withdrawals from this fund would be very infrequent.
We mentioned that a few of the counties have actually done major renovations in recent years.
And so it's likely another 30 or 40 years, in some cases, before a major project would be required again.
Another question that was asked before was how much does Sullivan County have in the bank right now we do have a capital reserve fund with about five million dollars in it we have been steadily trying to set aside money for this for this requirement we also have about seven million dollars remaining of our just over eight million that we received in ARPA funding so about 12 million is what is what we can kick in.
Again, we don't know what the next cost estimate will be for the project, but it will be most certainly north of $50 million.
So there will be a pretty sizable chunk left for our taxpayers to absorb.
I think that is all I wanted to say.
I can be mindful of the time, but I'm happy to answer any other questions.
Thank you.
Thank you for your testimony.
What was that, a 30-year bond you were looking at?
A 30-year, yes, a 29-year bond through the bond bank.
We ran different scenarios and that's okay representative Ames going forward with this on your own would lead to a 25% increase in the tax rate what is the tax rate now in the county on average is about three dollars per thousand but our tax the tax I should have said not tax rate the total taxes and we are our county tax bill is about 14 million dollars right now so a bond would be anywhere from three to four million depending on the term and the rate on average that's correct and one other point to just take other stab at trying to clarify the proportional issue based on the number of beds for the county.
We mentioned 56% of the beds in Sullivan County are at our facility.
And I think what we've observed is that the poorer counties are the more rural counties.
And those counties tend to have the higher percentage of beds at their county facility.
I think the reason is fairly evident.
It's that there's not as much private sector involvement in long-term care in those counties.
That's generally more of a you know the larger cities are the ones that enjoy greater involvement from the private sector so the burden there's a greater responsibility maybe not burdens probably not the right word but there's a greater responsibility for those poorer and more rural counties to provide this function for our seniors, but because they're the poorer counties, they have a harder time meeting this requirement.
So it's kind of an inverse relationship between the demand for these beds in the counties and the ability of those counties to pay for this mission set.
So I do think perhaps some additional discussions on putting a cap beyond the percentage that we've articulated in this draft would certainly be something worth discussing.
But the fact remains that it's a pretty big bill, and we're talking about counties with limited means to pay for this.
So can this project, contemplating the $50 million project, be broken into logical pieces?
Well, we have a phasing strategy.
That's what I meant.
Yes, it's being phased, but it can't be phased in distinct, separate projects that could be funded, say, five years apart.
I mean, all told, it's going to be about a three-year project with the various dominoes of trying to, you know, construct a piece.
You've got to keep the building going at the same time.
Right.
If we were building new, it would be a different animal.
But because we're trying to renovate and add on to it, we have to try to manage that appropriately so that we don't lose census during construction, which would create another fiscal impact during the construction period.
Any other questions?
Representative Janagian.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Just a quick question.
Thank you for taking my question.
You said you had about $7 million in ARPA money now.
Can you still apply for more, or are you already limited to that amount?
Based on your application, did you apply for $50 million?
I mean, how does that work?
How much can you apply for?
Thanks for your question.
The ARPA funding was just a flat number.
It was based on population.
So our allocation was just under $8.4 million.
We allocated about $1.4 million for some premium pay for our first responders, nursing staff, and our county attorney staff.
So 7 million is about what we'll have left over.
We have applied, and I think Chairman Cloutier mentioned this, through Senator Shaheen's office for a congressionally directed spending request, which my understanding was it was approved, but because the federal budget hasn't been passed yet, we have no word as to whether that will provide any additional federal funding.
That was a $2 million request.
So even if it is approved, it's really not going to be the answer to all of our prayers, but it certainly helps.
In terms of additional spending through the pending infrastructure bills, we don't foresee anything specific to nursing homes or long-term care facilities in those bills.
The focus is on a lot of other things, but not this.
So we've certainly kept our eyes out for any other opportunities through the federal government, but our own ARPA allocation is really all we've been told to expect to receive.
And again, small population, 44,000 people equated to about an $8 million total ARPA allocation, which is pretty small compared to what some other counties got.
So that 88 million allocation, you said based on population, but it wasn't necessarily a request directly for the nursing home build or rebuild.
No, the eligible uses for ARPA funding were specified by the Department of Treasury.
So that's what we're  we've kept most of it set aside for that purpose.
So follow-up.
So could you make a request for ARPA funding directly for renovations?
We could.
I don't know to whom that request would be directed because to my understanding there's no additional pot of ARPA funding.
Local governments got what they got, and so there was a formula that derived that amount.
And my understanding is there's no more to be had.
If there was, I probably would have heard about it by now, but I'll certainly be happy to continue exploring options.
Thank you.
So as a follow-up to that, so you've already submitted your plan for your upper money, correct?
Counties were fewer than, oh, gosh.
There was a population threshold.
We were below it, obviously.
We didn't have to submit a plan.
We just have to follow the guidelines that were obligated by the Treasury.
Okay, thank you.
We're rocking in.
We had to submit a plan.
That's why.
Thanks.
All right, any other questions?
All right, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Miss Tom?
Tom?
Yes.
You can fill out a pink card when we're done.
Sure.
But if we have any, HHS.
Yes, good afternoon.
My name is Kelly Tom.
I'm the department representative here today.
I am an attorney.
I am with the Bureau of General Counsel.
Specifically, I represent the Bureau of Licensing and Certifications.
So I am the Department Representative here today.
I'm happy to take back any questions that you do have.
Unfortunately, I am not the accountant in the Department, so I have limited expertise to share with you in regards to the funds within this proposed bill.
Okay.
I don't think we need to come up with questions today.
I think we can sleep on this, and then we can submit the questions to you to forward to the correct person.
Yes, we have my contact information, and I can certainly...
And then, especially when we get to work session on this, when we talk this through, we may have some questions.
Excellent.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Anybody have questions, though?
I don't want to...
Okay.
None.
Thank you very much.
Sure.
Okay.
Can we, Representative Janai Ging, see if any names on the...
Oh, first, anybody else want to.
Okay.
None.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Can we, Representative Janicki, see if any names on the...
Oh, first, anybody else want to testify on this bill?
No?
And we want to read the blue sheet if there's any names on there?
Yes.
No?
Oh, yes, it is because of the money.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, it is.
Representative Major knows.
I think in two or three weeks.
I think early February.
Right.
Yep.
How many names are there?
There's seven, four, and one against.
Just read the names real quick.
Okay.
So four, Judy Aaron, Derek Furland, Mary Bork, Ted Purdy, Kate Horgan, Representative Gary, sorry, I can't read the last name, and Representative Walt Stapleton against Greg Moore.
All right.
Thank you.
No further testimony.
I'm going to close the hearing on House Bill 1525.
Thank you all for being here.
Representative Almey.
I'm going to ask people that you don't sign it when you're testifying.
Yeah.
I have to leave at like five minutes too.
So I have to have a meeting with the governor.
So I can't.
So would you mind taking over?
When the time comes.
Okay.
And the prime sponsor.
I'm going to call the hearing on House Bill 1565 to order.
The prime sponsor Thank you, committee.
Thank you, committee.
Thank you, chairman and committee members for hearing this bill again today.
It is a doubleheader for me, I guess.
So today I present this bill to you along with an amendment to it because we wanted to clear up some language and I sent the amendment to you beforehand so you have that in front of you as well as the original bill but let me let me go through some things here in talking about this opioid abatement trust fund this fund for those of you who don't know, was established in March 2020.
Representative, you said there was an amendment?
Yeah, I sent it via email to the committee.
We do have a copy of it.
Oh, I'm sorry.
And I didn't see it myself, so, but she can speak to it.
I mean.
Let's see if I have a, I may have a copy of it.
Yeah, please, can you?
We'll get it printed.
Okay, thank you.
Our researcher isn't here.
She would make the run.
Oh, okay, good enough.
Thank you.
So do you have the.
We're going to get copies.
You have the number?
All right, thank you.
I'm so sorry about that.
So the Opioid Abatement Trust Fund was established in March 2020 through HB 1639, along with the advisory commission that oversees it.
The fund is used to support programs associated with the prevention, treatment, and recovery of substance use disorders.
Representative Snow, Senator Gary Danielson, and Senator Rosenwald did a fine job of crafting that initial legislation to get it all established quickly because a large settlement from the national litigation in Ohio seemed imminent.
It made perfect sense to establish a trust for New Hampshire given the situation at the time.
Stakeholders were told that the states with trusts would receive more money under the basic plus bonus settlement model.
And this model is a formula that rewards states with a larger settlement amount if they have a trust in place and get political subdivisions to agree to the settlements to avoid further litigation.
There were 23 political subdivisions here in our state, 10 counties and 13 municipalities, that joined the national litigation prior to September 1st, 2019.
In the calculation, the base is determined by factors such as each state's population, opioid fatalities, etc.
And the bonus is determined by the percentage of political subdivisions that agreed to the deal.
New Hampshire largely followed the 70-15-15 model recommended by the judge presiding over the national litigation in Ohio.
And 70% goes to the opioid abatement trust established by RSA 126A83.
And 15% goes to the 23 political subdivisions, again, the 10 counties and 13 municipalities that joined the national litigation prior to September 1st, 2019.
The default model includes 15% share for the state.
However, New Hampshire has decided to allocate its 15% portion to the trust.
So currently, it's 85% to the trust and 15% to the 23 political subdivisions that engaged in the original litigation.
What I'm proposing today is to make changes to that allocation in order to fix a population penalty and provide a more equitable distribution of settlement dollars to the 23 political subdivisions that represent the front lines in New Hampshire's ongoing opioid crisis.
These 23 subdivisions already have viable and successful programs that should continue to be funded to combat opioid prevention, addiction, and rehabilitation.
The population penalty that I referred to happens because of how the population is counted in the current formula.
Right now, the county share is decreased based on the population of a city or town that also participated in the original litigation.
So, for example, the population of Manchester and Nashua, which is 109,565 and 86,494 respectively, are deducted from the county population of Hillsborough County, 400,721, before calculating it against the total population in New Hampshire.
This reduces the county's share of the litigation award.
Counties are therefore penalized because municipalities in their county joined onto the litigation.
The amount of the penalization happens to Belknap is 39%, Cheshire 30%, Coas 30%, Hillsborough 49%, Merrimack 35%, Rockingham 19%, Stratford 49%, Sullivan County 31%, Carroll County and Grafton County did not have any reductions, did not have any population penalty.
So this is significant to the counties involved because it reduces funding for the whole range of opioid abatement activities that they already actively engage in at the county level.
The 23 entities join the litigation because they are the front lines for fighting the opioid epidemic.
This legislation I propose today increases the share for these 23 political subdivisions from 15% to approximately 53%.
That still leaves plenty of money in the fund for other municipalities to have access to.
It also ensures that significant amounts of money are not sitting in the fund being unused because the purpose of the settlement is to get money into the hands of effective programs to combat the opioid problem as soon as possible.
Getting the money out and distributed to these programs is of utmost importance.
There will still be plenty of money left in the fund for other political subdivisions to make use of.
Any other community in the state will be allowed to apply to the abatement trust to fund eligible activities.
The abatement trust will still receive a significant amount of any present or future settlement dollars.
And I believe that I'm presenting an equitable formula that is fair to all parties.
By allowing each subdivision a share of the settlement based on their full population, counties will receive their full and fair share of settlement dollars and solves this population penalty.
The municipality gets its full share, and so does the county.
With regard to the current allocation formula, look at it this way.
15% of any settlement is distributed among the 23 political subdivisions that sued prior to September 1st, 2019.
So let's say hypothetically the settlement was $1,000.
In this case, 23 subdivisions would divide up $150.
And each allocation would be prorated by each subdivision's population.
The problem is that because there's a mixture of counties and municipalities in the population-based distribution, some people would be counted twice, and you'd end up with a percentage amount over 100%.
In order to stay within the $150 amount allocated to the entire group, an adjustment, this population penalty, had to be applied to make the math work.
So really what I want to do here is change it so that the allocation factor calculates each of the 23 political subdivisions' fair share of the settlement first, based on their full population, as opposed to the current model, which calculates a pool of money that is shared.
So again the current formula creates a pool of funding that is then distributed among the 23 entities by population, whereas my change calculates each entity's direct share of settlement funds.
Why the difference?
Because we have a mix of counties and municipalities and we can't evenly distribute a pool of funding because of the double counting of some people.
And it's needed in order to not penalize counties.
And that's why I call the 40% number an allocation factor and not just simply call it a distribution.
So why 40%?
The basis for choosing 40% allocation factor was to achieve an equitable solution that would provide resources as fast and efficiently as possible to the communities in New Hampshire that represent the front lines of the opioid crisis.
Other states have changed their allocation models as well.
Arizona's model provides 56% to local governments.
Colorado provides 60%, and North Carolina provides 80%, with an additional 15% if they agree to work with the state.
That is the essence of this bill and the amendment I bring along with it just clarifies the calculation method as well as incorporates a few excellent points and changes that exist in a bill that Senator Rosenwald will also be presenting to her body and that's for them to look at.
So thank you for sharing your attention and I hope you'll correct the current allocation and equities by passing this bill and its amendment through the committee.
I also want to add that this bill also makes provisions for changes in when the distributions happen and some reporting changes to the current statute with regard to when the distributions are, how they're managed and distributed.
So that's basically it for this bill.
Again, the amendment that I am bringing adds a couple of points that were outlined in Senator Rosenwald's bill, which is to make a change so that the county nursing home supervisor or designee is not appointed by the governor, but is appointed by the New Hampshire Association of Counties.
And also, we want to add that the duties of the Opioid Abatement Advisory Commission, one of the goals that they want to do is support evidence-based prevention programs and service Thank you.
that the duties of the Opioid Abatement Advisory Commission, one of the goals that they want to do is support evidence-based prevention programs and services, including efforts to promote healthy, drug-free lifestyles, reduce isolation, build skills and competence, and facilitate community-based prevention efforts.
So that's the essence of the amendment, is basically to clear up a little bit of the wording for how the calculation is going to, you know, the funds are going to be distributed, as well as add these couple of points from the Senate bill.
I've got a couple of questions.
So, so are you trying to make the Senate bill and the House bill more similar?
A little bit, yeah.
Is that why you're doing that?
I figured since I was making a change to clarify one of the paragraphs that I'd also incorporate some of those.
But even with this, there's still differences between the two?
No, no.
I think the only other change was in the Senate bill was that instead of saying...
That's okay.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's very simple.
Instead of saying that the distribution of funds shall be based on the 2020 census, I think Senator Rosenwald added that it was supposed to be the last decennial census.
So I'm sitting in for Representative Major, and this kind of thing he always asks, can you provide us a chart of the current law and how the money is allocated, and the bill, how the money is allocated?
I have a spreadsheet, actually, that would show that.
Is that something you can give to the committee?
Yeah, I'll email it to you.
Can you?
Sure.
That would be helpful.
Okay.
Representative Elmy.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Is there a way to do this so that the counties get a fair amount of money, but that you aren't privileging the 13 municipalities, so I have no idea who they were, but managed to join the lawsuit from all the other municipalities in the state that are targeted by the opioid crisis and have been trying to do something about it.
I'm sorry, I don't...
It doesn't seem to me that joining the lawsuit qualifies you as at the front of the opioid crisis in this state the counties represent the whole state right but thank you for your question I just want to clarify that the the entities that were initially involved in the lawsuit, they felt that they wanted to put the work in to join the lawsuit because the settlement dollars were very important for programs that they already had in place.
But the way in which this allocation was initially drawn up penalizes the counties because it's a mixed allocation between counties and the municipalities within those counties.
And I just wanted to make it more equitable so that the counties are not losing out on dollars.
Now, the other municipalities that did not join in to the litigation certainly have the ability to apply for funds from this fund for any programs that they may be drawing up or coming up with or ones they already have in place.
but it's just that so these entities that were at the forefront of this fight and in the legal battle for this you know they can be served more quickly by allocating this out to them more quickly.
Could I ask...
Follow, follow.
Yes, follow.
Please, thank you.
What is going on in HHS, which apparently is going to be what all the other towns in the state are going to have to depend on.
And on is there money yet?
So do we know what's going on?
Or do they have plans yet for how they're funding through to be doing this I'm not a heroin problem us and northern Sullivan County since a woman moved in from Boston about 25 years ago and started addicting everybody in the area to heroin.
And the opioid crisis is dumped on top of that.
And Dartmouth-Hitchcock has made itself, and we have a number of other places that are working on it too, but has made itself a leader in this area.
Thank you for that.
I only know what the allocation is through this opioid abatement trust fund.
I'm not aware of what other projects or programs DHHS may have which will help municipalities deal with this addiction problem thank you so you mentioned a spreadsheet that I think you're going to provide.
Does that have on it the list of the identities of the group that did file in the lawsuit?
Yes.
So, okay.
I want to be sure we get that.
That's all I'm going to have to.
Yeah, absolutely.
I can read them out to you if you'd like.
Well.
we can wait.
Okay.
Thank you very, very much.
Any other questions?
No, thank you.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Before we call up a net witness, I've got to everybody, I have to meet with the governor at three.
So about five minutes to three, I'm going to be leaving.
Representative Almi's ranking member is going to be chairing.
So I'm going to call up James Buffetti from the Department of Justice.
And I apologize that I may be leaving in the middle of your testimony, sir.
And there are two other cards after that.
Thank you much mr.
chairman my name is James Buffetti I'm an associate attorney general I'm the director of the division of legal counsel at the DOJ and since 2015 I've been the state's lead prosecutor in all of its opioid litigation and there are many cases that are working its way where we're going to begin a trial on February 1st in Merrimack County Superior Court against Johnson & Johnson for what we allege are their deceptive opioid sales and for bringing in huge amounts of opioids into this state, causing a public nuisance.
I'm here to testify in strong opposition to this bill.
And let me explain to you why.
When this legislation was crafted, we reached an agreement with the litigating subdivisions.
And that was an agreement where we all shook hands and said, this is a fair way of using the money.
15% of whatever money would come in off the top would go to those 23 litigating subdivisions.
The state would take no money and put all of the 85% into the opioid abatement trust fund.
So let's talk a little bit about these litigating subdivisions.
I've been litigating cases against the opioid companies for since 2015.
All of the work, all of the work in litigating these cases have been done by the Department of Justice.
None of the work have been done by these litigating subdivisions.
Here's some frank talk.
What happened here was an outside law firm came in and convinced the counties and some political subdivisions to file a generic lawsuit and that they would work on a contingency fee basis and they promised them them huge amounts of money.
All of those cases were then sent to the federal court in Ohio, which is a multi-district litigation court, and all of those cases have been stayed.
There has been absolutely no litigation done on those cases.
It is not true to say that they are on the forefront because I applaud them for filing lawsuits.
They didn't join a national lawsuit.
They filed individual generic complaints and all of those cases have been stayed.
There has been no discovery, no depositions, no litigation at all.
So the question is how do they do those 23 subdivisions that filed these generic lawsuits with the help of contingency fee council how to how do they get the bulk of this money to the exclusion of every other community in New Hampshire and there's no good answer for that because you know go to go to Exeter or go to Portsmouth or go to Hudson or Hooksit or Pelham or Peterborough and say to them you didn't get pitched a deal by an outside counsel you didn't file this generic lawsuit therefore you don't get any of these We think that is completely unfair.
We think it doesn't address the opioid abatement problem in this state and we strongly oppose it and would urge you to reject this bill.
There is a there is a format in place and the format provides that 85% of this money goes to an opioid abatement commission.
That commission hasn't even begun its work yet.
We just approved rules.
Those are going in front of Jelka later this year.
Hopefully they will approve it.
The object is to take all that money to receive applications from any political subdivision in the state and to figure out what is the best way of spending money to abate the opioid crisis, whether it's to a state agency or to the town of Hudson.
But each agency would have the opportunity to make an application to the Opioid Abatement Commission.
We would then try and figure out how to juggle those competing interests.
And then what our recommendations would be made to the governor and executive council for them to award contracts that they thought were the best way of dealing with this crisis.
That's the system for doing it.
That's the fair system for doing it.
That's a way that we can have a commission that is made up of state of the state rep.
There's a state senator.
There are county officials, city town officials, treatment people, a broad range of 22 or so commission members.
We can work as a group to figure out the best way of spending this money.
That's the way to do it.
And frankly, I'm disappointed that the people who sat across the table and shook my hand and agreed to a compromise bill that became what is law have now reneged on that because that's not what we had agreed to.
And this was a framework that should be allowed to actually play out and to see if we need to change it, that's fine.
The time for doing that is not now.
Okay, I got a quick question before I leave.
I hate to leave, and this is very interesting.
So how much money has been settled?
How much money are we talking about right now?
I know that it sounds like there's other cases as well.
It sounds like the AG's office is going to be managing those funds, like you're doing a lot of other settlements.
So how much, how much, is any settlement money come in as yet?
Yes.
So there has been one small settlement, which by the way, that those, those 23 political subdivisions never got involved with.
They never even named that person, that company, as a defendant.
It was a company called McKinsey, which was an advertising group that helped Purdue Pharma and Johnson & Johnson hyper-sale their opioids.
They settled.
New Hampshire received their first payment of $2.7 million.
Under the statute, 15% of that was distributed to those 23 subdivisions so for approximately four hundred and fifteen thousand dollars were distributed according to the population of those of those districts so that money has gone out there was approximately two point three million dollars in the opioid trust fund we're waiting for Jelka to approve the rules so that we can beginning getting get that money out.
Trust me, our goal is to get that money and to get it out as quickly as we can.
I expect with all the different settlements that we're talking millions of dollars over maybe 18 years.
But I mean, I, 150 million, I don't, I mean, it's hard to predict, but it's gonna be millions of dollars that will come into the state over 18 years.
And the goal is to figure out the best way of doing it so that we can prevent people from dying on the streets of Nashua from opioid overdoses.
Okay, questions, Urza, Ames.
So as I understand it, you had a handshake deal that did provide 15% to this group of political subdivisions and counties, I guess, who filed.
And that tells me that going into the discussion that led to that handshake deal, your position was they should get less than 15%.
Right.
And that's sort of consistent with what you've said to us.
And so you made a deal.
And 15% was a little above what you thought was right.
It was below, obviously, what that group thought was right.
And that was the deal.
Do I understand it correctly?
Yes.
So our position is, and I think the state law supports it, the complaints that these subdivisions brought, they shouldn't have been bringing them at all.
They weren't state claims.
They weren't local claims.
They didn't belong to Sullivan County.
Those were state claims.
And that so we could have gone into court and asked a court to extinguish all of those cases the subdivisions brought.
And they knew that.
And because they knew that, we were able to reach, we figured, look, it's much better to try and reach an agreement, right, instead of having to go and litigate.
So they all knew that, and we showed them the case that said you can't bring these, these aren't state claims, these aren't local claims, they're state claims.
And so as a compromise we said how about if 15% off the top goes to you.
I still don't understand why they should get 15% because again they didn't I mean they filed complaints I get it there their contingency fee council on their behalf filed these generic complaints but that's all they did why does that entitle them to to these extra payments to the exclusion of all the rest of the state it no one can answer that question for me there's not a good answer for that and frankly it's a it's you know it's a problem but it's a it's a deal that we reached and so when that money came in from McKinsey we we complied with the statute we paid the 15% out as quickly as we could to those litigating subdivisions.
And and can I just say that there was a point made about double counting.
So you know know, I mean, I haven't seen the amendment, so I can't speak to the amendment.
But I can tell you that the original copy of the bill, it changed dramatically the way that this money was distributed.
So we don't want to double count people.
So for instance, in Hillsborough County, Manchester was one of those litigating subdivisions, as was Nashua.
And so in order to be fair to the rest of the state, we have to deduct the population of Manchester, the population of Nashua from Hillsborough County to figure out how much that Hillsborough County should get because Nashua and Manchester are getting a portion of that and so that's not that's that's preventing double counting so that that there is money then they can go to to Belknap County and to Coas County that because otherwise Hillsborough would get all the money in this in the settlement and let me say also that you know maybe this has changed in the amendment but if you read in the the bill from line 7 to 9 this is what this is what the bill says the distribution of funds shall be based on the 2020 census population of each qualifying county and political subdivision, multiplied by the amount of the settlement, multiplied by an allocation factor of 40.
Well, I'm not a mathematician.
I would readily admit it.
But if you spin that out, so Manchester has 109,000 people approximately.
Say we get a settlement of $5 million.
You multiply 109 by 5 million, which is what it says you do.
You get a figure of 545 billion.
And then you multiply it by 40%, you get $218 billion.
That can't be right.
I don't know what that formula means, but it's not a usable formula.
The other thing that hasn't been mentioned is that there's a provision, maybe this has changed in the amendment, but there's a provision starting in line 12 that says that no later than January 15, any outstanding balance in the trust fund shall be distributed just to those 23 subdivisions.
So, for instance, we settle with a company and we get a payment on January 5th of $10 million.
Right?
$10 million.
According to this bill, on January 15th, all $10 million goes just to those 23 subdivisions how can that be I mean that just that just that just can't that does is not a workable thing and and not to mention this you know there's this questions about if there's encumbered funds that have been awarded but not yet left the the trust fund the legislation doesn't mention that but you know those are things that obviously could be clarified the general the general principle though that you would reward these subdivisions to the exclusion of so many others in the state it is something that at the AG's office looking at the larger picture of the entire state and the needs, we could not support.
All set, Representative.
And to the point you just made, and maybe my question is relative, it may not be, but was the handshake agreement on the first settlement, or is it all settlements going forward?
It's all settlements.
So it was way before that settlement was It was prior to this legislation of being proposed.
So we as a group of City and County officials.
It was a working group.
We put together this bill that became what is now RSA 126 a 83 to 86 and and we it because we we knew that we needed to have a structure in place to deal with these opioid funds and we knew that we had to use these monies these monies for opioid abatement purposes because we wouldn't have been able to accept the monies because this is how they were coming through with these settlements so the the bankruptcy judge in Purdue Pharma, right, in White Plains, New York, made it very clear that all of the money that we would receive, when we do receive it, has to be used for opioid abatement.
So we needed a structure in the state to deal with this influx of opioid funds from any source to any source, any subdivision that received money.
So we proposed this bill.
We had hearings in the House and the Senate, and the bill was passed.
This settlement that I talked about, this McKinsey settlement, happened a year or so after all that happened.
Any further questions?
Okay.
Thank you questions?
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you very much.
Derek Furland, if I'm pronouncing this correctly.
Thank you.
thank you mr.
chair and once again ladies and gentlemen of the committee thank you for providing me this opportunity to speak with you today once again Derek Furland I'm the county manager for Sullivan County passing around my written testimony as well as a letter of support from the New Hampshire Association of counties so rather than review what's being provided to you right now I guess I probably make better use of my time responding to mr.
some of mr.
buffetti's, as well as some of the questions that have been asked thus far of Representative Aaron.
I think the handshake deal characterized by Mr.
Buffetti and the fact that it was legislation that was crafted, I think the word crafted is generous.
I think this legislation was put together in a very compressed timeline.
And I don't mean to say that as a negative or derogatory.
That timeline was thrust upon us and was driven by events in that national litigation in Ohio.
The thought process at the time was that a settlement was imminent and that states that had a trust that would protect these funds and ensure that they were spent on opioid abatement activities would in fact get a larger share of the settlement dollars.
So it was one to protect the funds.
I think there was too much institutional memory of the tobacco settlement when funding did not go towards tobacco related abatement.
So it was a hedge against to protect the interests of the defendants as well as a deal to try to get more cooperation from among the states.
So that all happened in the fall of 2019 after the normal process and window for submitting legislation had passed.
So it was, again, I'd say rushed through, but I don't mean to say that in a negative or derogatory manner it was just simply a pragmatic way to try to get this legislation done um so it subsequently was not subject to the standard uh review process that most bills are subject to like what we're doing here today um and then by the time that the final bill was being circulated it was now march of 2020 and everyone's collective focus was was squarely on covid so it just didn't quite have the same level of scrutiny and i think some of the uh what i would characterize as defects of that original legislation are what we're trying to rectify through this proposed bill um but as far as the handshake deal there there never was a grand bargain of all 23 entities.
I mean Sullivan County was never represented in those negotiations.
So I'm not exactly who was in the room with the Attorney General's staff, but I can assure you that it was not anything that was representative of all the interests and equities of the 23 parties that had joined that national litigation.
As far as the claim that the subdivisions haven't done any work, there's been a lot of work done, just maybe not that has been on the radar of the Attorney General's office.
We've spent hundreds of hours justifying the past expenses, working with our national attorneys in hopes of trying to bolster those negotiations of what that future settlement would look like.
But when the focus was not so much on past claims as it was on future abatement activities, a lot of that work unfortunately has kind of gone for naught.
But it doesn't eliminate the fact that we did.
The county staff spent hundreds of hours detailing all of the opioid-related costs that we've incurred, whether it's through the county attorney's offices, the sheriff's offices, or our county jails.
And those costs have been significant.
Yes, it's true the state is suing Johnson & Johnson.
I guess I'd remind the committee that Johnson & Johnson currently is 2-0 in their various lawsuits across the country.
So I wish the Attorney General's staff well, and I hope that they have better success.
But so far, they've proven to be a pretty formidable opponent in other courts.
The national litigation that we have joined has over 30 litigants and defendants.
The state has taken action against just a handful.
So the prospect of more settlement dollars coming to the state ostensibly will be a result of the fact that we are taking action against the 30-plus defendants.
Again, those resources will be shared according to the formula in the trust, I want to make it sound like this is an adversarial thing between the counties and the municipalities that joined in the Attorney General's office.
I think there's been a tremendous opportunity for some collaboration.
I mean, by working together, we're going to enhance the amount of settlement dollars that come to the state of New Hampshire, and that's driven by the base plus bonus scheme that the national settlement is proposing, which simply just the more subdivisions join in with the state, then the greater the share will be.
So I know Sullivan County has agreed to join in, and I'm quite confident that most, if not all, of the other 23 subdivisions have as well.
As far as a previous comment or question about the perceived unfairness with the 23 that did decide to join and other towns and cities in the state that did not join, all I can simply say is two points.
Number one, there was a 15-month window where any entity could have joined this national lawsuit.
We joined in June of 2018, and any entity had until September 1st of 2019 to decide to join.
And I'll say that the bar for joining was very low.
It was simply a letter signed by our governing board authorizing us to join the national litigation.
So very, very easy to join.
Number two is that even with this revised formula, there is still going to be a significant amount of funding under the purview of this trust and governed by the commission.
So any entity that decided not to join for whatever reason can still avail themselves of this trust, which again will have a significant amount of funding in it to help them with their opioid abatement activities and programs.
One other note on the population penalty, you know, this just, the urgency and the importance with which we wanted to address this in this bill was simply because the counties are a separate entity and we have our own programs that are distinct, and I would argue in some cases, maybe not for all 10 counties, but certainly in Sullivan, the programs that we run absolutely dwarf any of the opioid abatement activities that are performed by our municipal brethren.
Our county jail, we have in-house, in-resident drug treatment programs.
We have counselors and clinicians.
We provide medical-assisted treatment.
And these programs and these people, they cost quite a bit of money.
We also are in the final stages of opening a transitional housing facility in the city of Claremont that's going to have up to 28 beds for people who are transitioning out of our Department of Corrections treatment program.
That program will also cost quite a bit of money.
So to the extent that we can leverage these funds, it just saves our county taxpayers that much money.
The distribution language Mr.
Buffetti pointed out, he's absolutely right.
That language was confusing, and it was absolutely not the intent of the original bill that was drafted to drain the fund no later than January 15th.
That language has subsequently been rectified in the proposed amendment that Representative Aaron has provided.
So we concurred with his with his concerns that that it was confusing and we and we took steps to fix that and then as far one last point I wanted to make too is with regard to where are the front lines in this crisis yes every community has been touched by this there's no doubt about it we have believe, 232 towns and cities or 234, and we have 10 counties.
And there's not a single person in this room who probably hasn't personally got some experience of the negative side of opioid addiction and the evils that come with it.
I will say that of the 23 entities that joined the national litigation, the 13 municipalities represent 10 of the 13 largest cities in the state of New Hampshire.
Altogether is about 40, approaching 40 percent of the state's total population.
So giving more resources directly to those entities, I think, is a sensible and pragmatic thing to do given the amount of people that we're talking, the communities that we're talking about.
It's Manchester, Nashua, Concord, Keene, Laconia.
You know, this is where the largest population centers are in the state.
That's where the biggest opioid problems are on a per capita basis.
And so I think it's right to provide those resources directly to them and not have to necessarily go through the bureaucracy and I don't again don't mean that in a pejorative manner but as Mr.
Buffetti mentioned the the commission is still a year onward trying to figure out their rules for for getting those grants I'll tell you that the $9,300 that Sullivan County received last year as part of that McKinsey settlement we had spent within a month it was easy easy because we had the construction for our sober housing project, but it just goes to show that we have ongoing plans and programs that need funding and having to wait for rulemaking and to compete with other grants, I think, um, is not the best way to go about combating the opioid crisis.
Pending any questions, that concludes my statement.
Thank you for your time okay representative Ames thank you so I'm back to the handshake deal I'm just trying to understand what happened and maybe it's a misnomer for all I know but was this group of litigating, filing municipalities and counties represented by the same council or group of law firms?
There are a few law firms.
My understanding is that the national firm that we have represents most of the counties but not all and a handful of the municipalities, but I couldn't you who they are off the top of my head so where I'm going to and you may see this but it's one thing if if the deal really didn't involve everybody and that you weren't wasn't a point person or a point law firm that was talking to the Attorney General.
If that's the case, if there wasn't such an arrangement, then there's no deal.
But if indeed you were talking, you had somebody who was negotiating with the Attorney General, then that sounds very different to me and something that we have to worry about here.
Well, I can tell you our attorney did not support the legislation that's drafted, so I don't know if our attorney had conversations.
I mean, there's a lot going on, and so I haven't really kept up with every single conversation.
I'll also mention the 70-15-15 structure.
That was a default structure of an allocation model that Judge Polster in Ohio recommended.
This wasn't something that we crafted in whatever those negotiations were.
So that was just, that was the standard default model.
And as Representative Aaron mentioned, some states have decided that's not going to work for them and they want more money to go directly to the front lines.
And I think we should follow suit.
Any further questions thank you mr.
Furland testimony I've got one last pink card and for the life of me I can't make out Tom's skin no worries no worries my My name is Tom Mullins.
I'm the city attorney for the city of Keene.
And thank you to the chair and to the committee for taking the time to talk with us.
I was only coming here basically to tell you that I support the bill as amended at this point.
But I have to tell you quite frankly that after hearing the comments of the associate attorney general, I'm a bit shocked.
I'm also very unhappy.
It's hard for me not to take some personal and professional umbrage at that.
I'm sure that Attorney Buffetti wasn't expecting anything like that and I'm sure that we could shake hands and move on after this.
But here's the reality.
The reality is that we met with the Attorney General at that point and with Attorney Buffetti, a number of us, the communities, the counties, when this issue about creating this trust was first raised.
And I know that I specifically objected to using the MBTE trust as a model for these settlement proceeds.
We also objected to the 15% that was being suggested at that point.
At that meeting, there was a request on the members who were there to participate in a working group to try and craft some legislation to present with respect to these issues.
I know I volunteered to be on that group and I think that there were others.
I never heard another word from the Attorney General's office with respect to this.
I've worked very closely with our outside legal counsel and as far as I understand and know any conversations that they had with the Attorney General's office also echoed those concerns and comments.
To the extent that the Attorney General picked a working group, that's certainly the Attorney General's prerogative.
I wasn't involved in that group.
That's certainly the Attorney General's prerogative.
but to represent that all of us who participated either in that meeting or with respect to the underlying litigation signed off on this agreement in some kind of deal is really troubling to me.
As far as I'm concerned, that raises the question of bad faith in negotiations.
In order to have bad faith in negotiations, it seems to me you need to be in negotiations in the first place.
So none of that happened.
So with all due respect to the Associate Attorney General.
With respect to the amendments that are being proposed on this, the way it first went into the committee and the way you have it now was something even I objected to.
I know that Attorney Buffetti raised that concern.
When you first read the language, all of the proceeds essentially went to the 23 municipalities or the settling entities, and then everybody else got cut out of that process.
We had that conversation.
I said, that's not appropriate.
That wasn't what the intention was at this point, and they needed to be able to have those funds.
With respect to who's on the forefront and who isn't, I think that there's a confusion here.
The forefront isn't necessarily the litigation itself.
The forefront is all the human cost that's happened out there in these municipalities and in the counties with respect to this crisis.
To say that we haven't been on the forefront of the opioid crisis is beyond disingenuous, quite frankly.
Our police, our fire, our human services, our hospitals, they're the ones dealing with this crisis.
And as the county administrator pointed out, the 23 municipalities and counties that are involved in this are the bulk of the population in this state.
We need these funds.
I'm here to support the 40% allocation directly to these municipalities with the understanding that the town of Greenfield can file a request for money if they need that.
That was never the intention.
But the obvious reality is we need to be able to have the resources because this is a continuing crisis at this point.
I know, Mr.
Chairman, you're looking at your watch, and I apologize for that.
I said five minutes.
Not my purpose.
I had to take a few of those minutes to assuage my professional unhappiness at this point.
So I would urge you to consider and to pass and to make a recommendation on this, on the 40% allocation, for us to take the money to be able to do what we need to do with it.
And I suppose the last comment that I'd like to make, barring any questions at this point, and again, and I do have to correct the Associate Attorney General, he made reference to a case Thank you.
comment that I'd like to make, barring any questions at this point, and again, and I do have to correct the Associate Attorney General, he made reference to a case that the Attorney General's office represented would just allow them to scoop whatever litigation we had out there.
That was the city of Dover, the state via the city of Dover.
It happened in 2006.
Just point out to the committee and anybody who may be otherwise listening, that case arose in a very different procedural context.
This is not a slam dump for the Attorney General's office to pull these cases away from the municipalities and into the state, and I raised that with the Attorney General at that meeting.
The reality is we, City of Keene, the other municipalities initiated a lawsuit, numerous lawsuits on this crisis.
And I believe, I could be wrong about this, before the state initiated anything.
This idea that we didn't do anything as part of this litigation is again just not factual.
We had to collect information through our fire department, police department, human services department, all of the information we collect with respect to the cost that we had to expend for this crisis and are continuing to expend on this crisis.
So I would urge you please to consider this amendment and to adopt the HB 1565 as the amendment has been presented to you and I'm happy to answer any questions that you may have.
Thank you.
Any questions?
Representative Balmy.
Thank you.
I can sympathize with you, but I wanted to ask if you would be willing to accept that we are all on the forefront of this, that there is no forefront, that it is all over the state, that the very small towns, that the small cities that did not participate because they don't have as much capacity as the bigger ones do to do that, also need help.
and does that context does this the way it is written now give twice as much help per population to the bigger places than to the smaller places on its face the bill provides more resources to those 23 municipalities.
There is no doubt about that.
But again, as was pointed out, those municipalities constitute a bulk of the population in the state.
In response to your question, it's still true that the other municipalities who didn't participate, who didn't have either the technical expertise or didn't understand.
I used to live in a small community.
I know that.
I used to be the moderator in my town.
We could never call outside legal counsel because it costs money to do that, right?
So we understand that and the bill doesn't take away anything from them other than the additional monies that are going to go to the 23 municipalities.
And back to your comment earlier that was made, if you don't mind, Madam, is the idea that the counties, remember, the counties and the municipalities have different responsibilities.
The municipalities have the fire departments, have the police departments, have the human services departments, not that the counties don don't have human services but there's a mix of responsibilities between those two so just providing the funds to the counties would not resolve the issues on the local level thank you but being that they are different I've been doing this for 26 years now so I pretty well and I started with the county stuff on that given that they are different.
I've been doing this for 26 years now, so I pretty well, and I started with the county stuff, that given that they are different, doing different things, you can't say there are 23 municipalities.
There are 10 counties which are operating on county stuff all over the state, and there are the 13 largest cities in the state yes and then leaving out everybody else uh well rather leaving out everybody else not leaving them out right but leaving them in a much later and lesser position in terms of getting funding well remember even Even under the existing bill bill those entities that didn't file a lawsuit prior to September 1st of 2019 are still in the same position with respect to that they still have to apply through the committee for grant funding and not in that kind of thing and just to point out we have concerns about that as well I to our public works director before I came over here, because this is modeled on the MBTE settlement that was approved.
And we've had unbelievable difficulties trying to get any money out of the MBTE settlement with respect to that.
And I hear that primarily part of the reason for that is there's a rules problem on that.
And we've heard that this entity hasn't established its rules either at this point.
So going through that bureaucracy to try and get funding is going to be challenging.
Okay.
Which means left out.
Representative Schomburg.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for your presentation.
You mentioned about accounting.
Is there an accounting procedure that each of these towns or subdivisions or counties will have to submit to the AG's office?
The simple answer is yes.
Funds that come in even through the statute as amended are needed to be accounted for.
They're through the committee and HHS, I'm pretty sure.
Is that a simpler process than what is being asked of you now?
Well, so far we've only received $7,500, so it's been fairly simple at this point.
But our finance department has already geared up to account for the funds and other spent any further question fantastic thank you very much for your time all right and seeing no other pink slips close testimony on 1565.
Oh, I didn't have the blue sheet.
John, Representative Janigian, do you mind?
My apologies.
Thank you.
I didn't want the job.
Okay, four.
We have seven people, four.
Representative Judy Aaron, Derek Furland, Mary Bork, Kate Horgan, Walter Stapleton, Representative Cloutier, Tom Mullins, James Buffetti.
I'm sorry.
Those were the four.
And against are James Profetti and Kate Frey.
Thank you, Representative.
I'd just like to request in future that since we don't, people don't remember the rules anymore, but if you're doing the testimony, you aren't supposed to sign the blue sheet.
So maybe we could just not read those that have testified.
Thank you.
Thank you all.
See you Thursday.
Here, you edited it, correct?
Thank you.